Oh, game!
We're doing...
Pragmatah!
Oh hiyoo!
Howdy, howdy.
Oh, chat broke.
Thank you.
It will do.
Just say something.
I'll fix it.
If I am able to.
Unless I'm, like, in mid-beddle.
Hello!
I'm ready to play.
I don't even...
You know, I could yap.
But honestly, I think I'm ready to just apply.
Let's take your daughter to work day.
Yeah.
I have been playing this game off stream a little bit.
Because I was like, oh, well, what if I go back and do some
of the areas that like, I mean, it was only two areas that I
did.
And I was like, you know, what if I go back 100% them.
And so I did do that.
Except there was one thing that I couldn't do because I
don't have the, I guess the ability to yet.
But I saved all story stuff.
Hello, Kevin.
All story stuff for stream.
Good luck on stream, me too.
This game is so fun and I'm glad to see you enjoying it.
Section 3 is so pretty.
I'm so excited.
Thank you for so!
Come on, thank you!
Hello, Minto and I, Buzai-Q.
Very happy to see you playing some more of this.
I've been playing a bit on the side of the combat.
It's very addicting.
That's how I feel.
It feels so...
It's so satisfying.
Play Pragmata or watch Minto play Pragmata.
You could do both.
Probably.
Before you start, how are you feeling today?
Any better?
Darko, thank you!
I actually, I woke up and I was feeling so much better.
Um...
I was like, well, I still have a little bit of, like,
something with my ear.
So I'll still go.
I had a doctor's appointment.
I was like, I will still go.
But, like, my throat does not hurt so much, really, at all.
But I did the doctor's appointment, and the doctor was just
like, okay.
We can see you tomorrow.
doctor's appointment i was like okay she was like you can
come to the doctor's office but you need to make an
appointment i was like okay and she was like you can you
call at midnight i was like what she was like if you call
the doctors at midnight and ask for a same day appointment
then they will be able to there were only two slots we will
if you are fast and lucky you will get a slot and i'm like
oh uh and she was like many people know about this hack so
you have to be fast what the doctor gotcha yeah i'm like
wait what what
What?
Doctors come at midnight to camp?
Doctors hate this one trick.
Yeah, I was like, wait, so people are like calling at
midnight to get a same day appointment?
And there's only two slots?
So I'm fighting against who knows how many people?
Is this a thing?
I wonder if you need a different doctor.
I might.
I was like, what the hell?
So, um, I decided that I will probably not do that.
And I will probably go to one of the places that's not on my
insurance.
Because what the hell?
But they're not the same.
I don't know.
I just...
At the same time, it's like, doctor's greet goes crazy.
It's...
At the same time, it's like...
Do I pay the hundreds of dollars or do I gotcha?
I don't even know.
I don't know.
It's so wild.
See, wear priests clothes and carries holy water?
I sure hope not.
I don't think I would be taken out by holy water, though.
I'm only a little evil, maybe.
I'm not, I'm not a demon, but I could become one.
Thanks for being the first mainstream ENV-2 to play Ace
Combat because most of the two are only JPV.
Thank you, Nan!
I am having so much fun.
Yeah, so, um, around midnight, I will decide what I want to
do.
Let me show you guys.
We have some things that I want to do.
And catch up on.
Thank you for letting me know about the hack though.
I honestly don't think it's a real thing.
I'm like, am I being pranked right now?
So...
To show...
Look, I am at night.
100% and 94% I don't think I will probably 100% the game
Actually, I will not 100% the game on stream But I will off
stream most likely Now you say it, medical bills do feel
like wailing Depending on insurance, sometimes ER is cheaper
than urgent care It could be worth checking If I'm feeling
good, I definitely don't want to go to ER though Because at
the ER, you wait for a million hours Yeah.
Um, there's some things in the mass production array that I
want to go to because they're story related.
So we will do that.
And erm, I have these things.
Let's give Diana her toys!
Even big bots don't stand a chance when we work together.
I thought she said big boss.
I thought she said big boss!
Looks like we're getting the hang of this.
Thank you.
Let's head to the caradone.
Yeah.
To find eight.
Do you think she's okay?
She sounded in trouble.
I don't know.
Guess we'll find out when we get there.
Hey, don't you get tired of hanging around the shelter?
I want to experience again.
Thanks, Brian.
If so, let me send her cats.
We can borrow the hard work you do that we don't see.
Thank you.
You'll be a big one.
white furball maybe next time kiddo i just remember there's
something else i gotta do the classic line to kids oh sorry
i'm busy to play your imaginary game aren't you tired i
don't get tired are you getting sleepy no i'm sleepy i don't
really get tired y'all i'm sleepy oh no come back we're
talking aren't you tired i don't get tired no okay present
but i got a I got a skateboard, so we're going to be
balling.
I'm so excited.
Whoa!
That coin.
Yes.
You, I've got a surprise.
You're going to love it.
You, thanks for everything.
Oh.
So, do you like it?
Is that you?
Wait.
That cat.
I drew lots, but this one turned out.
Is that an iPhone?
So, I'm going to.
I'm giving it to you.
Hey!
It's actually pretty good.
Shows you're a real cat lover.
What's that?
You guys!
Yay!
What's the way?
Why is it blue?
You.
Can you dribble?
You there?
Yeah, I'm here.
Hold on.
I'm still in shock.
It looks just like you.
I'm right here.
That is literally an eyeball!
With a full grown body!
Tell me a story!
Yes!
Diana, if you ever need anything, let me know.
She's so... Tell me a story!
She's so funny.
I want to watch her dribble.
Come on, dribble, dribble!
Dribble, dribble!
That's your... Yeah, that's your final evolution.
Yeah?
She wants my attention, but I don't know for what here.
Let's give her the next present.
A skateboard.
Calvin coin.
It's a board with wheels.
Am I supposed to ride it?
Yes.
What is she doing?
No, please.
Do you need me to pick you up?
Do you know how to dribble?
Do I know how to dribble?
I could dribble.
What was that song?
My money don't flow it.
Dribble, dribble.
Wait, she's going.
She's going.
She's gonna go dribble.
She's gonna go b-ball.
She's balling.
Yes!
No!
Play with your new toys, Diana!
Don't jiggle, jiggle.
It fold.
Diana, wrong toy.
She really, she hates it.
She hates sports.
She loves the color and hates sports.
Um, but anyway, um, I have gotten all of my upgrades to
level 8.
Yes, yes, yes.
So relatable.
She's like a cat for real.
She's a cat for real.
I do want to do some upgrades before.
we go um actually there there's some other stuff i need to
check too let's do sorry there's so much stuff let's do it
we'll we'll bingo here sweeper bot bingo thank you bingo
what's this
hacking node that exploits enemy weaknesses making the next
hack deal critical damage and more easily stagger the target
passing through multiple nodes of the same type increased
damage oh we have not seen that fella before wait a second
that guy's new hmm spider bot wait who are these guys one of
our we hope you enjoy your purchase well it's one of your
more popular items who this.
Tutorial, tutorial, tutorial, what can I say?!
Wait!
Tut-t-t-t-t-t-torial spoilers.
Oh, this guy's called a spider.
Little spitter.
And then the sweeper...
Oh, I...
Wait.
Flying bot with unknown code looks similar to the SR6 assist
bot.
Wait, maybe we don't know this guy.
Hacking them gives lots of filament.
Luna filament.
I did get a secret log.
Wait, maybe...
Wait, what's the one in the cradle?
Or, sorry.
In the cabin...
down because there's this one this is secret of port day one
okay we'll wait to grab this one once we get more cabin
coins we'll do day one and then day two please come and see
us again psycho tutorial and i also i i the only one i
haven't gotten is the complete within 80 seconds i'm too
slow i'm too slow
But, I could always give us a cabin coin.
But I got everything else.
And then I even, I even got a little crown on this one.
Slowpoke.
Yeah.
Oh, before we go, I will do the upgrade.
So, um...
um i have these two mega thingies i was thinking i don't
have enough for um for like both a mod slot and a node slot
but there's also like i don't know about the auto hacking i
don't know how good it is but also like upgrades to like the
shock wave gone and things like that vivicourt thank you you
change your profile picture more than anyone i've ever ever
in my whole after life.
I rarely use the auto hack.
I don't think I will.
I'm wondering if a node slot, a nerd slot, or a mod slot
would be good.
We could even repair up.
I forget I have it.
Did you say No, I said node.
Clean your ears, everybody.
Sorry.
Auto-hack is useful later on, but it isn't good to just rely
on.
Yeah, yeah.
That makes sense.
I do want to start upgrading my hacking things, but before
then, we can, I guess, make another...
I guess if we got the nerd slot, it would max it out.
So, Kodanya!
Thank you so much for the fine cuter!
Thank you!
Can you clean our ears?
I would take the Q-tip and I would shove it in.
And I would...
And I would... I've... I've...
Straight in the drums.
You 100% said nerd that time.
No!
Why would I say nerd?
It literally says nerd slot!
You guys crazy?
Let's get the nerd slot.
I forgot.
Well, we could always save up for the mod slot.
I don't have enough anyway.
I would have to get the auto hacking.
Maybe ear cleaning ASMR is off the venue.
Maybe.
But yes, before we...
Let's try.
Expose.
Multi-hack.
We're not actually going out, going out.
We might have to fight a little bit if all goes wrong, but
pocket refinery.
Oh, nice.
But, um, we're gonna go back to the mass production array
before we go to the Terra Dome because there was some lore
stuff that I want to read.
Let's go to the office space.
And as you can see, there are two boxes I'm missing.
But unfortunately, I can't unlock them yet.
Why would Minta lie to us?
I am always serious.
The Terror Dome.
But Diana and Mint are so cute.
Thank you.
Alrighty, let's get some little lore bits.
Right, quick.
I know exactly where they are.
Wee!
In here.
Up here.
That thing right there.
So, see this?
I just wanted to see what happens here.
Alright.
What is this stuff?
Is this...
Luna filament?
I don't think so.
Also, its basic compositional structure seems a bit off.
It's all messed up.
Like it's glitched out or something.
Ah, so that was pretty short.
But that's okay.
There was also something I wanted to read.
Pretty...
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Pretty much these parts are very short.
I just have to...
I just wanted to get them on stream with you guys first.
And if you're also like...
Oh, I'm not...
Well, then all this is here.
Then now you know it's here.
I forgot that there was this part.
Great find.
Yeah!
You can use me as your let's play guide.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Hidden gems.
Earth hidden gems you won't want to miss.
Well, what are they?
A Wesker production What could they be?
What are the gems?
They're holding out on us.
They're not sharing them.
Uh, yeah, we can still go this way.
And we'll go this away.
Search it.
Where does the domain take us to?
Is this the door?
Yes.
Just a little bit overkill using all that on this guy.
Oh, the explosion spooked me.
I actually jumped.
Go to the URL.
You go.
Tell me what's there.
What's at the URL?
No such thing as overkill.
Oh.
Um, oops.
We will just be going home.
though all right so if we go through here jump up here oh
that's not what i wanted i wanted to jump and jump and grab
come on just jump and grab there we go
if we go through here there is a hidden door right here
and this lore I thought lunar hideout I thought this would
be a big stuffy company but I quickly found out that
everyone here is a massive weirdo I guess that just means
I'm in good company that's exactly why I always wanted to
work here though no one's breathing down my neck no pressure
to conform just pure creative freedom I even got the chance
to dig into the cradle's design history each sector was
assigned to a different contractor, and they all let their
AIs run wild, however they pleased.
Fellow weirdos.
Because of that, the hallways, trams, and sector layouts are
messed up.
Oh, no.
What?
The AI didn't do a good job?
The AI was wrong?
It's inconvenient to get anywhere around here.
Without direction, from the AI in charge.
I'd probably end up wandering around lost for days.
But that's the best part.
It's 100 times more exciting than your typical 9-5 office
space.
Plus, I love that I can make my own little hideouts, too.
Sharon.
Wait, so...
They look like this normally?
Besides, like, this stuff?
I thought all the walls were sideways and everything because
it all got messed up.
Is it because...
Huh.
Now we go back.
That's all that I wanted to get.
Very exciting office space.
Yeah.
It's like the Winchester mansion.
The lady that built that mansion in California that has
walls and staircases that lead to nowhere.
What?
She's on the skateboard!
Oh, yeah!
The design is so simple, but it's actually pretty hard to
write.
You're a hidden earth gem.
I thought you wrote worm.
I'm a hidden earthworm.
If I were an earthworm, I think you know.
Look at her goal!
Yeah, you'd still love me as a worm.
Push!
I think she's using it correctly.
To be honest.
I think she's using it pretty well.
Alrighty.
Oh yeah, that thing.
What thing?
What's she doing?
Ah, the ball's rolling away.
Oh, she's got a basketball.
Most kids use skateboards like that.
Probably.
Oh.
Is she gonna play with it?
I'll play.
I'll grab it.
Let me have it.
Let me add it.
These are the stiffest balls ever.
Oh my goodness.
Let's go to the Terra Dome!
New area!
Yippee!
I'll keep what I have.
Okay.
Okay, Teradol!
Why are you guys saying, Eyo?
I can't handle it.
Chad, she's so unbearably cute.
Also, hey, Diana is on a skateboard.
Nice.
That's one way to say it.
Is that not correct?
New area, let's go!
She knows ball!
Ah, so fist up!
Thank you!
Hmm.
Hmm...
Let's go.
You know where we can find this A character?
Um... Nope.
Tree.
Wow!
Area 3!
I like how it just says that.
Wow!
Is that a bird?
No way there's birds.
You can almost smell the nature.
Are they robot birds or?
Oh, they are.
Do you get something for shooting them?
I hope not.
I don't want to shoot the bird.
This place took some serious funding.
I better pay off when I get there.
This place is huge.
Birds aren't real.
Well, then tell me what flew in front of me.
yesterday.
I almost got hit by a duck.
Why do I hear like a snake?
Oh, I can actually go down this.
Wait, is that wise?
Oh, geez.
I have no choice now.
Here we go.
Just kidding.
I meant to do that.
Okay.
Okay, I already got it.
Pretty sure the hiss is your suit.
Oh no, it's this.
It's the bushes.
There's one right there.
There are other animals here too.
Do not touch.
Yeah, I hope there's other animals here too.
I hope we have like a million animals and they don't attack.
They're really nice and they love us.
I hope that's what happens.
I imagine that we can do this.
Why does that one box there look like a trap?
Oh no, no!
Maybe not.
Wait.
Let's go this way.
Do not touch.
Triple dash to it from there?
Oh, you're so right!
We could do that instead.
You're scary.
Okay.
I got a land on it.
I don't even need the triple dash I only needed a double
dash we're too good we're too good triple dash
where's this ladder go my game needs more invisible walls so
you remember anything about eight No, I just felt like I'd
heard her voice before.
But that's about it.
So many birds.
I never did meet someone who could talk using a cat.
Pretty strange.
Not like we got a lot of leads.
Seeing how we can't reach Earth.
Nick's family.
They deserve to hear what happened.
You know, in person.
Oh.
Friend.
Do not touch.
There's more down there.
I keep thinking it's snakes.
Sounds like little snakes hissing at me.
I feel like I'm...
Where'd you come from?
What
was he doing?
Sabotage, sabotage.
Probably.
It's a troll.
I should have known.
It was quiet for too long, you know?
Oh, ow, ow.
Good job, good job, Hugh.
Good job.
I keep seeing these blue bags and I'm thinking they're like
body bags or something, you know?
Kind of freaking me out.
Oh.
They're freaking me out a little bit.
Nice save, thank you.
Cash money!
Cash filament!
The elicious.
Are those bones?
Now that you mentioned it.
Am I the only one noticing this?
Thinking about it?
I mean, where is everybody?
We still don't know.
It's still so mysterious and strange.
Whoa, whoa, was the tree mid print or is this just an
aesthetic choice?
Oh!
Oh.
The heck with that?
High power blade.
Oh,
shoot.
Don't worry about it.
Samurai.
Yeah, this is cool.
he's got his little hat and everything.
I wish I saw him attack more.
I don't know.
Look, they're like...
I'm gonna shoot it.
I'm gonna shoot the bird.
Okay, it doesn't do anything.
Thank goodness.
Thank goodness I didn't want to shoot the bird.
I didn't want to do it.
Wow.
Look, even the ceiling is like simulated sky.
Like, it's a little messed up, but... I feel like Dad Space,
you also like Dead Space.
I've never played Dead Space.
I think I might like it.
But...
I don't know.
You control the buttons you press.
Yeah, but I didn't want to press it.
I was forced by science.
Science forced me to push the button earth's biodiversity
among the stars welcome to the teradome using the latest
lunar filament output technology built on plant growth
algorithms we bring the complex environments of earth to
life here on the lunar surface step aboard the central lift
and explore every area everything you see here was printed
with one and only oh with the one and only lunar filament
attention certain research areas involve hazardous
experiments I'm glad to see that Mint is a good father.
I am!
I would not jump into the abyss with my daughter.
I fell into the abyss with my daughter.
Visitors must be accompanied by a guide.
Oh, what does that say?
Neo-Core?
Neo-Core.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
No, all the snakes!
snakes escape that's what I was hearing the snakes is there
a difference of course there is one was oh please initiate a
manual reboot of the limb regulator okay good they didn't
think that I was the abnormal plant growth that'd be pretty
bad oh
Uh-oh.
Who's there?
No.
I hate this guy.
Edis is playing games with us again.
That tree was getting smaller.
But then Edis got in the way.
Yeah.
Why would Edis say that it's unauthorized?
I... what is... oh.
I think I'm authorized to do it.
Oh, am I glad we found you?
Nice.
Hmm.
Do you
hear me?
Eat!
Kitty!
You're here.
Thank you.
I miss my cat.
You're close now.
Just take the central lift and I'm there.
Hey, what are we supposed to do about this big old tree in
the way?
Yeah.
We boot the two limb regulators, one in each area.
but um are we are we able to do that okay hang in there
eight there's got to be another way rescue eight all right
let's go to this place first oh what's this oh those are
butterflies not sure oh they look like monarch right yeah
stuff's Pretty sweet.
Just liking sweet things is something we both share.
Is bitter bad, then?
Nah, it's not bad.
It's just...
Bitter badder...
Betty butter, butter, butter made her bitter bad.
Wait, that sounds fun.
Betty...
Betty bought some butter, but it made her bitter better.
Her badder better.
Betty went and bought some better butter.
Oh.
I thought you were a cat.
Like a cat variant, like cat ears.
Oh, there's multiple of them.
Hmm.
What if they go after me?
They don't even notice!
They're so lame.
Go after the...
Go after...
Oh.
Haha, that's not me.
actually you're kind of stupid actually you're stupid for
real actually you're so dumb oh my god they didn't even
notice there's actually so stupid I think
maybe I'm the stupid one for using it hoping that it would
like activate them and they'd be like oh so somebody's there
no they're just really really dumb stupid robots Luna
filament trees it's the teradome luna filament printed trees
are fully managed by ai in the eco modeling lab from growth
to dismantling our goal is to develop trees that can
continue expanding their structure naturally with water and
sunlight even after printing for now some manual handling is
still required simply insert a gen chip into the dedicated
replicate dedicated replicator to output the regulated
amount of luna filament it's seriously a tongue twister a
little dedicated luna Well, you won't be able to get across
like this.
Laser tree.
Stasis nut.
No.
Maybe?
Nah.
Tuna?
Where?
I got you.
Bingo!
Who's down here?
This area is giving me portal 2 vibes.
Actually this area feels extremely portal 2.
Stasis net again?
I think there was something up there.
Hold on.
Let me...
Oh, I thought those were legs!
I was gonna say who is she?
Spice.
Here, let's do this.
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me yet.
Okay, just kidding.
All right, then.
We go back to here?
Well, well.
You're not like the others.
Ah!
It might shoot something out of the round thing.
Uh...
Oh!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da!
It's on now, Tinkad.
Take this!
Yay!
He just shoots things?
Where'd he come from?
Wow, so pretty.
This area is so nice.
Gen chip.
Accelerates growth of...
Okay, cool.
So this is what the thing was talking about.
This chip holds a license to generate quasi-organic plant
material.
Worth a shot.
Worth a shot, baby.
Yeah.
How close?
and height is beat up to Diana.
I don't know.
It's working.
That'll do.
That looks terrible.
Oh, what?
Ow!
I don't even notice that guy.
Holy cow.
I don't even notice him here.
He's so small and tiny and insignificant.
I would have never seen him.
Nice, we're getting lots of upgrades today.
Yeah.
He was camouflaged.
Well, clearly he wasn't doing a great job at it.
Now I see...
What's up, Amir?
Secret rule.
It wasn't so secret, though.
Actually, it was quite obvious, I'd say.
like the most obvious secret room that we found.
Vanishing act.
I hardly ever go back to my own room anymore.
I just love setting up a wall in some corner and working to
my heart's content.
There's a whole window!
Like anybody could see you in here.
That's how I knew it was here.
Now you just have a big brain.
When I get bored, I simply find somewhere else to stake out.
Yesterday a new scientist joined the lab.
You don't go to your room and sleep in their own bed?
He wouldn't stop bombarding me with questions.
He seemed pretty naive.
Honestly, I would...
Oh, honestly.
I was hoping for a spirited discussion about advanced
materials research, but all he wanted to talk about were my
favorite movies and places I wanted to visit.
Oh, sorry, but I really don't have time for that right now.
He also kept asking me what room I was in.
that's weird
that's like meeting someone for the first time and asking
their address I fibbed just to get him off my back only to
catch him sneaking around behind me Jesus I put up a wall
with my mobile replicator and finally managed to give him
the slip I bet I'm the only one here who could get one
printed that fast he looked like he saw a ghost and I got a
good laugh out of it maybe I'll try that few more times.
Share it.
Can I hack that from here?
No.
Maybe, um...
Hmm.
Where could we...
I guess from down there.
Oh, sorry.
That was my phone.
La la la la la.
Hoi.
Oh.
Oh, that was fresh.
I love Sharon.
She's such a troll.
I hope Sharon's okay.
I do wonder.
I'm so curious.
My biggest curious.
My biggest thing right now is like what happened to the
people, you know?
Where are they?
Where are the people?
No sneak attack?
Okay.
My biggest curious.
Yeah.
your guesses.
Look at all the trees.
Pretty cool.
Now, where's that regulator hiding?
Maybe over there.
Through that door?
Yeah, but how are we going to get there?
What if we generate more branches to cross?
Not a bad idea.
Let's go find some chips.
Oh, oh, wait, is that a red room?
No way.
Oh my gosh, it's right next to the thing.
That's pretty nice.
Eco modeling lab.
Whoa, what's in there though?
Red room.
Oh, that was our footsteps.
I'm scoping the area.
Oh, there's some...
There's a sword guy down there.
I see him.
What are you?
What was your purpose?
What were you built for?
Fences are down.
Open drive protocol.
Oh,
shoot.
That's not what I wanted to do.
That's okay.
I can't tell where he is.
Oh, his head is his weak point.
I couldn't tell before.
He's supposed to be a samurai.
He's...
There's a chip over there.
This?
No, this is a chip.
Tippy.
Tippy, tip, tip.
Maybe he's the guide.
He's not so scary though when I shoot at him from up the
stairs.
Two more left.
Tippy, tip, tip, tip.
I don't know why it gets me every time now.
You know?
right there, you know?
But it still gets me.
I know they're right there.
There's also Earth Memory.
Balloons!
Filled with helium.
These balloons float gently in the air.
A light breeze or spark of static might send them drifting
unexpectedly.
Be sure to tie them down securely so they don't float away.
I can't wait to get back to the shelter.
What's this?
Can't go in.
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Oh!
Don't open!
Ah!
It's a hit!
I keep...
It's my turn.
Wooly!
Yeah, stupid.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
They didn't give me any this time.
That's fine.
Actually, we needed to open him up again.
It's okay.
We'll take him down.
Is there anyone else in here?
No one?
Secret room?
How did he get in?
Wait.
Performance tests.
These limb replicators are convenient, but the massive
influx of power they require means they inevitably end up
bulky.
What if Sharon is all to blame for this?
Wouldn't that be so funny?
If Sharon ended up becoming the villain and was just like,
yeah.
Actually, I lost, I went, I went crazy.
I wanted to try running one on a mobile power source.
So I created a mini handheld replicator using an EVA.
An EVA suit.
As a battery.
Evangelion.
And I'd say it was about 30% successful.
It was pretty handy, but it guzzled electricity.
It'd take about four or five batteries just to make a wall
like this.
That defeats the point of miniaturization in the first
place.
Still, mistakes are half the fun of discovery.
but I'm happier that way.
Call it playing around if you like.
But at least I'm doing what I love.
Shea rune.
Uh-oh.
Dead end.
Oh.
Gosh, don't.
This way doesn't lead to a regulator after all.
Don't scare me like that.
I want to see the branches generate again.
Wait, this is another...
Oh, increases hacking gauge buildup by 15%.
Oh.
When successfully completing a hack.
Well, look who's in a chipper mood.
Okay, cool.
We'll take that.
I'm going to be guzzling electricity.
Where did this?
We came from over here, so we go this way.
There's another earth?
There's another REM?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, it's safe.
Oh,
I'll take that.
Thank you.
Um, I guess.
We'll grab.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't see a way to get it from here.
Oh, that's a window.
Oh.
I thought it was just, never mind.
Right on, baby.
Yeah, right on.
Why can't, why won't our thing?
open these.
Why can't we open them?
What is this?
Oh, no, what is...
Sticky bombs!
A tactical unit that fires sticky bombs that adhere to
targets.
Attached bombs temporarily shrink the hacking matrix and
deal damage on explosion.
Effects can stack.
Oh, look at that!
Wait, that's kind Oh, so you can shoot it like three times.
Whoa.
Love how good.
Boom.
Okay, I'll try it.
I don't know how...
What is that to help me hack?
I feel like I don't know how good I'm gonna be at that,
but...
With the slower guys, I'm sure it's great.
Do you see anyone?
The area is so pretty.
It's like I'm in the jungles of Russia.
Oh, I think we're gonna wanna use that then.
Oh, holy!
He's all legs!
Holy cow!
Uh, wait.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
Hehehehe.
Oh, wait.
Ah, no, I missed it.
I missed it.
That's okay, though.
Oh, we got him.
He's all legs.
Sticky bombs.
Those were cute.
I like them.
Charge.
that was strong i know is this another one yes thank you i
think it was three wasn't it one more to go yes sticky
bounds i like that you can like kind of get more ammo from
picking up you know the the weapons, and then it, like,
leaves the rest of the ammo there.
Hi, Aminto.
Hello.
Oh.
What's that?
Red gate here.
Oh, no.
Red zone.
Here we come.
No, no.
No.
I can still hear the moose.
Now that you say it, I won't unhear it.
area guide meteorology sim lab the meteorology simulation
lab is dedicated to observing luna filament printed plant
samples under a wide range of simulated natural weather
conditions on earth plants evolve to endure storms droughts
and other extremes by instilling that same resilience into
luna filament trees we can create hardier growths that
promise to greatly improve daily life
be hardy.
Bad weather.
Is there good weather too?
People have good moods and bad, right?
It's the same thing.
So they're purposely trying to make the earth angry.
I guess so.
Aggressive?
Yeah, make the earth angry.
Aggressive defense.
Reduces damage received by 20% while aiming your weapon.
Oh, man.
Your suit's gonna be so tough.
Yeah, baby.
you want to go back to the center and recoup i do not i'm
i'm dedicated but i'm i feel like something's gonna pop out
of here once i grab this no wait what is it oh something oh
that is like a that's like a ladder
is it from hmm is there something down here that we missed.
Oh, I did not go down that way yet.
I'll keep those there so that I remember to go back down
that way.
Look up!
Area 9.
What am I looking up at?
Gamers don't...
What was that?
Up top?
Oh, that's the thing!
It's a heart!
Get away!
That was so cute!
That was so stinking cute!
I only look up when I'm told to.
I follow like a dang dog.
Oh!
They would have said, hey bozo.
There's a guy there.
Oh gosh.
this looks awfully intimidating
like what could that be let's go back down
guys i have a feeling that that was suspicious also there's
like one little limb up there how am i supposed to eat you
no we'll come back i want to go down here real quick oh
actually a shockwave is probably fine there's got to be
someone hiding right in here oh it's the it's the red stuff
I can't eat yet where you were in here I picked the wrong
crate you were in the wrong crate
Oh, shoot.
Holy cow.
Scared me.
What?
Oh.
I was anticipating the wrong thing.
My gamer's instinct was wrong.
My gamer instinct.
And there's not even anything here.
Not that I can get it.
Oh, I lied.
No, I guess not.
Three.
Three upgrades.
I can't clear this yet.
I imagine it leads to some really scary zones, though.
Something on the ground back there?
The weapon?
I don't need it.
It's okay.
Oh, there's some I can defeat.
Or I can get rid of there, though.
I can get rid of the blue.
I'm guessing I have to go into this room for the last chip.
But before that,
before that, actually can I get rid of a hero?
I can!
Much better.
Is this not the,
I have, is this not the red room?
Is this not the red zone?
But I, but I, maybe not.
But it won't let me open that until I defeat all the
enemies.
No.
Let's go back and do some upgrade.
But when I come back, everything is going to...
All the enemies are going to be back.
That's fine, though.
That's okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
There weren't that many guys in here.
Uh...
But I do want to upgrade before we go into that big, big
room, you know.
Just go in.
Okay.
I might die.
I'd rather...
Which way do I go?
That room seems like story.
This room seems just like...
You have ult ready.
That's fair.
That's true.
I do.
Good job.
Good job, Hugh.
I love when he uses his arms, unlike other games.
characters and games and all.
I see three pods right there.
Or two or three?
Three.
Right there.
I wish I had my shoddy.
Oh!
Oh, that's many more than...
Holy...
Holy cow.
Back off!
Ah!
Oh, oh shoot, uh...
Oh!
Damn it.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Wait, who is that?
That guy over there.
I'm gonna miss him though.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Holy cow.
Uh...
Oh, I should shoot him.
Wait.
Ow!
Watch out!
There's more!
I don't think I need my...
Uh...
I think I'm okay for now.
If there's any more spawn, then we can use my old...
It's okay!
We did it!
We did it, team?
I will take that.
Cool.
What?
Holy!
I just realized how much money I have!
Yeah, baby!
Try healing.
Wait, I probably should heal, right?
Well, hmm.
Yeah.
I think we're okay.
Can I get back up here?
Wait.
No.
Wait, do I really have to go all the way around?
This is so inconvenient.
What's down here?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Alright.
Riot Blast.
Oh, that's the thing I switched out for the sticky bombs.
We'll try out the sticky bombs for whatever is in the big
room.
Diana's holding on well.
Two years with my ghost, Yoshi!
Love you, Rinto.
Thank you, Raccoon!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I really, really appreciate it.
So the last one has got to be in this big, scary room then.
I wonder, maybe it's just an ambush rather than like a
mini-boss type of situation.
We'll see.
Actually, I kind of prefer the mini-boss.
Not going back for upgrades.
I don't know.
We'll see if I need to.
Okay, one, two, three.
Something up there maybe?
Oh shit.
Initiating weather simulation test.
Oh, weather simulation test!
The boss won't react well to that.
Oh, I see.
Give him a little shock, shall we?
Oh, I could just...
He'll get shocked.
Oh, me too.
I will also get shot.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh.
Yay!
Okay.
Uh.
We can't get him, though.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah!
I was trying to get out of the way.
I thought I was out of it.
What the hell?
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oops.
I got him.
We got him?
Wait, I forgot to charge it.
I missed!
Oops, bye, bud.
That's so silly.
Why don't you come over here?
Oh, watch out.
I thought it was in there.
See, that's what I thought I was before.
That's so funny.
Uh...
Oh.
Wait!
It's on now!
Take care!
Take this!
Consider that a warning shot!
Was that it?
Oh, that literally wasn't nearly as bad as I thought it
would be.
Oh, what's this?
Uh...
Oh, come on.
I guess maybe it's below me.
Yeah, the decoy generators, they definitely were like, Hey,
by the way, you want to use that, buddy?
One, two, three.
Same as before?
Plus?
Plus or minus?
I'm like, do I want to go back and upgrade?
Actually, let me heal.
We'll heal instead.
And I can ult.
Okay.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot!
We got the lightning again.
Oh!
We got the lightning again!
Wait,
please.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Moving!
They're all stupid.
It's okay.
Shockwave!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, but please, please, please, please, please!
Swap!
There we go.
so awesome
what's this oh sticky bombs oh man it took my it took my
kill you took my kill oh okay uh there's some really scary
guys here oh
oh shit i tried to i tried to get out oh that sucks Oh, that
was pretty bad.
That was pretty bad.
That was greedy.
It's from my greed, my greed.
Our green knows no bounds!
The happy one.
Did I do it?
Oh, that was close.
Mark a bot and its matrix will shrink.
That was close.
Sheesh.
Okay.
Surely we're safe in here.
Surely they wouldn't give us something else.
What's this?
Is everything sorted for the big inspection by management
next week?
We just need to list the soil sample data from the lightning
labs we ran earlier.
The study to enrich soil fertility with nitrogen oxide
via...
Not the cleanest fight, but good recovery.
Thank you.
Sonia!
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
But the current model was just too cost prohibitive.
But if we use lightning generators made from Lin, we can get
positive results at a fraction of the price.
Sounds promising.
This might be what we need.
to get biomass back in the dead zones good very good let's
name the report how lightning will save our earth
trees there it is yeah I don't know what the accents are
either all right now Yippee!
No more chips.
Oh?
Let's reboot that regulator and go help Ape.
Yep.
Where are we?
On it.
Faculty guide.
Closed test areas.
At the performance test range, bots undergo lightning
resistance training.
As this is a high-risk test entry is strictly prohibited for
all unauthorized personnel.
Oh.
What was vaguely Australian, maybe?
Reckless entry, it may result in serious injury.
Test unit, sector guard, Lancer.
And then.
Forward, forward, forward.
Return to Earth's request.
Hey, I saw your test results.
It looked like you passed.
That's too bad.
I guess they put AI in charge.
of the test so faking a poor performance turned out to be
too obvious i'm sorry i know you're trying to get home and i
understand the pain you're in but look on the bright side
positions like this aren't available just to anyone you made
it here because of your hard work and dedication try to keep
your head up everyone was trying to get out of here
where did this oh this is that one area i was like where the
heck are we Oh, that's really convenient though.
It literally put us right back where we need to put in the
chips.
Hi, Aminto!
Hi, Brandon!
I hope you're doing well too!
Thank you for the super charge!
Ta-da!
It's work!
As it should.
What?
Ta-da!
Shut up, Hugh, I'm not done.
I'm not done, Hugh.
I'm wondering if I should go back.
No, I think we're okay.
Well, my health.
Surely they'll have a thing.
I don't want to go in, but I'm kind of also curious.
I'm curious at the same time.
Curious.
But I won't, because I'll definitely die.
I'll definitely die.
Well, I one-shotted the last one.
Who knows?
I'm looking around.
Wait, I've been forgetting.
ABS, always be scanning.
I forgot to be scanning.
What's there?
Oh, here?
I think I found an REM.
Phew, let's check it out.
I found...
There's so much.
Oop.
Oh,
somehow I always jump sideways.
Oh, that's not good.
Got it.
Because I understand our toes.
Oh.
Let's head back and upgrade.
We just got to parkour again.
No big deal.
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh-huh.
In here?
Oh!
Ah!
I'm killing my partner.
Yeah!
Oh, the scanning is so nice.
Holy cow.
Did I miss one down there?
Wait, before we return though, while all the bots are away.
And the Minto is at play.
Oh, I forgot to go in here.
This seems like a trap.
No?
It seems like a trap, no?
The no said they were testing the sector guard there.
It was the first boss you faced.
Ah!
I'm scared.
Why else would they give me this?
This is definitely...
Even more?
Wait, I can't go in there.
Hmm.
Freebie.
That's crazy.
Picking up a mod close by.
Any idea what it does?
Down below.
Come on.
Well, no, when we
get...
Oh.
Hmm.
I'm not quite sure.
Actually.
Mito, I finally got my degree!
I wanted to thank you.
Thank you for all the good times throughout the years.
And goodbye!
Congratulations!
That's huge!
You got your degree, you're so smart.
This is down here!
Okay, I give up.
Let's go, let's go back home.
All right.
And we'll upgrade.
Alright.
We gotta heal up.
What have you been up to, Hugh?
Nothing much.
How about you?
That tree was so big.
Guess that's why the lift wouldn't work.
If we reboot the limb regulators, it should clear a path.
Yeah.
Yep, that's what Eight said.
Alright.
Can we try climbing the tree before it's gone?
Climbing, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, I could come to that.
We're just gonna...
Yeah, why don't we just climb up then?
How can a little chatterbox like you stay quiet for so long
in storage?
It was easy.
I was in sleep mode.
And...
He's so cute.
There was no one else to talk to either.
No!
You were the only one in there?
I think so.
I didn't see any other bots or humans.
No!
Must have been lonely.
Lonely?
I don't know about that, but it was pretty boring.
She knows boring.
I found you so quickly.
She gets boring, but doesn't understand lonely.
Hugh, is something wrong?
Oh, oh, no.
I was just thinking about Nicholas.
One of the guys I came here with as a daughter.
I didn't want to pry, but I imagine she's about the same age
as you.
It'll be okay, Hugh.
Even if Nicholas is gone, I'll still be here for you.
I'll try my best to surpass his efficiency.
That's not the issue here.
I can't just replace someone who's dead.
You gotta understand that I'll never see Nicholas again.
And neither will his daughter.
Oh, I don't want to end it there.
What's that?
Wait, wait.
I don't want to end it there.
Ah, the ball's rolling away.
Why is my ball stuck?
I think my game is It's a glitch.
She can't play basketball.
I put the ball away, but somehow it rolls off.
So I pick it up to put it back, but end up playing with it
again.
That's just what it wants.
Ball stuck.
Sometimes toys and books just pull your strings like that.
Pull my strings?
How?
Beats me.
How does she have?
What strings?
They don't like being left alone.
What strings are we talking about?
Wait, didn't we have a present?
Balloons, that's right!
Balloons!
We just have the one left!
The one that we can't get quite yet.
They're floating!
But how?
Gas?
Gas!
Gas, gas, gas, gas, gas, gaz, gas.
Gas, gas, gas, gas, gas, gas!
Ha ha ha ha!
I am ghost.
Gas, gas, gas, gas.
The balloons are so cute!
How they float like that!
Wait a sec!
if we make lots more and tie them to me do you think I could
fly do you think she weighs like a normal human weight
really?
then I can fly not gonna lie a bunch of kids have already
tried that but on the moon it might actually work I'm gonna
make it happen you ever play any of those games that kids
are into like hide and seek hide and seek you hide someone
finds you rinse and repeat I was a master at it not a single
person could find me you I think you're too big to hide now
here oh my god we can play I'll hide first come and find me
okay one two three oh
guys where is she oh I'm over here oh you found me You won't
buy me next time.
Win at hide and seek.
Wait, I want to play.
They can play again.
Let's play hide and seek.
One, two, she's so fast.
Well, there is a timer, I just realized.
She's so cute.
You're not supposed to tell me...
Wait, actually, I don't know where she is.
You're not supposed to tell me where you're...
Wait, I'm gonna lose this time.
lose because we gotta...
I actually don't know where she is, though.
Do you guys see her?
Where is she?
Am I crazy?
Like, I can hear her voice.
Sounds so close.
We couldn't find you!
Also, we have a new uh oh god what's wrong with him is he
okay all right we have 16 upgrades holy moly canola um and
then we also have 5 000 limb we can upgrade so much let's go
i will get a new
here i don't know yet Let's do this one first.
Let's upgrade!
Everything.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
And we can do one last thing.
Ammo capacity 8!
I feel like hacking, though, is probably our best thing.
So we'll do hacking.
Yeah.
Yes!
Okay.
Then, we do...
Okay, I do wanna upgrade these.
So I'm gonna upgrade basically...
This?
You know?
Freeze.
Expose.
So I've been trying to use this.
Okay, so passing through offensive nodes or gunfire will
increase the damage of the next hack.
So I've been trying to, like, pass through them, and then I,
like...
Okay, wait.
So I'm kind of confused by it.
So I...
So when I hack, it'll give an increased 444 damage.
How spooky.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I've been doing it correctly.
Um...
Freeze!
Put your hands up.
We'll do another mod slot then.
Because that will also max it out.
And then we can work on the repair ups.
Later.
Oh.
I'm even gonna upgrade.
I'm gonna max my overdrive as well.
Especially because we have it already at already.
Complete, complete.
What's the difference between max and complete?
I get...
Like, will these upgrade more later?
Mod slots are never bad.
Yeah, yeah, so...
Wasn't sure.
Maybe max means there's still more tiers later.
Complete equals done.
Max is unlock later.
Okie dokie.
Cool.
That's exactly what I thought.
Um...
Multi-hack I think would be really good to keep.
But we'll do...
Freeze.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't do any of these either though.
Um, we'll do this so we can at least have it.
There's still one other gun that we haven't been able to
unlock yet.
Max can increase with another shelter key.
Got it.
Very cool.
Next I want to do more decoy gun because the duration longer
would be pretty nice.
Stasis net would also be pretty nice.
We can go, we'll do some more weapons and stuff after this.
Oh, we also got a cabin coin.
Yeah, baby, yeah.
La la la.
Oh.
Great.
Now we are honored to provide water.
One of our greatest goods.
Thank you for your patronage.
Now we can do this.
So we have cradle infiltration log day one.
I finally got in.
Audio check.
One, two.
Okay, levels are good.
Better to nail down the narration first and I'll worry about
the transcription later.
This...
Okay, this is six pages.
This marks my first entry, a moment worth celebrating.
My name is Daniel Galliano, once a reporter from Prime World
Publishing, but I quit to hell with them.
Anyway, I'm hunting for the biggest scoops out there.
You may not know who I am, but in two weeks' time, you will.
At last, I've successfully infiltrated Delphi's lunar base,
the cradle.
Next step, disembark from the transport deck and make my way
to the data center.
First order of business, blend in and greet the staff.
my camera rolling when all of a sudden security flagged me
censoring my feed what a pain i guess i have no choice but
to use my handy cam instead and edit the footage later this
little fella's a relic from my personal collection and it
doesn't require a network connection so the security ai
can't interfere as for digitizing the videos i'll worry
about that later oh my gosh but already so many of our
things are like connected to internet to use the orbital
elevators looking pretty different these days.
If memory serves, it didn't have that massive ring-shaped
structure before, so curiosity got the bust of me.
I asked some of the staff here to fill me in.
Apparently that enormous ring is a limb replicator, a 3D
printer of sorts.
Delphi's been keeping it under wraps.
But what if they... but if what they told me is true?
The replicator itself is also made from Luna Filament.
Fascinating.
So using something made of Luna Filament to create more Luna
Filament I wonder if that's like making it all funky.
I see how it is.
Delphi has done it again.
I didn't know what to expect from the so-called saint of the
tech world.
But this?
They freaking...
Oh, they hit the freaking jackpot!
Built a giant printer, cut out transport costs entirely,
simple, ruthless genius.
With this tech, the moon isn't just a frontier anymore.
It's their personal piggy bank.
Yeah, a 3D printed 3D printer.
That's a wrap for today.
Tomorrow, I'll talk to the rest of the data center staff and
try to get clearance to access the Terra Dome.
If my gut is right, and it's always right, there's plenty of
dirt waiting to be uncovered, especially on him.
Who's him?
Things are starting to get interesting.
Cradle Infiltration Log Day 2.
This is one of his five pages.
Digging begins.
Getting someone to open up isn't rocket science.
Got into Ace Combat 7 after seeing you play 4 yesterday.
Now I move my mouse in first.
That's why you got to play with a controller.
I'm hope you're enjoying it, Malcolm.
Powerpuff Girls, him?
Oh, yeah.
You know, him.
That guy.
Each and every one of us carries a secret which we're dying
to spill.
But the real prize, it's the innocent ones.
The kind-hearted, soft-spoken types who wouldn't hurt a fly.
They're the ones who end up confessing their wildest
secrets.
This is where I come in.
Glad I brought that occult- occult magazine with my article
in it.
Wait, this guy's a freak.
Always a good conversation starter, and as usual, they
always take the bait.
Print media is pretty rare these days.
A third-rate rag full of sketchy headlines and sensational
BS, but around here, even that counts as decent
entertainment.
Some of the staff still cared about the cradle's public
image.
The truth is, the buzz died down a long time ago.
These days, people just see it as a passion project picked
up by some indulgent corporation.
A company still recovering from a failed government venture,
chasing a dream that won't ever turn a profit.
When I told them that, some of them actually looked pleased
with themselves.
I don't get these brainy act types.
I know, it really must be a boring place.
What did they do for fun here?
the 20 get the nico thank you so so much to be brutally
honest the food here kind of sucks and don't get me started
on that chicken platter they can try to imitate the flavor
all they want but in the end it'll always be synthetic trash
these people have been shoveling this crap down their pie
holes for two years now i guess living on the moon really
screws with their standards count me out but i gotta say
artificial wine isn't too bad gets the job done at least Day
two has been pretty good.
A little bit of this and a little bit of that.
Before I knew it, I talked to every member on the data team.
Pace up cake.
Tomorrow I'll be checking out the Terra Dome.
If I keep up this pace, I should be wrapped up by day four.
No, day three.
Oh, how I look forward to finally meeting him.
Oh my gosh, what if it is moonshine?
That's so funny.
Alright.
Uh, maybe we'll try the sticky bombs.
for whatever is going on.
Our hacking nodes will do freeze, decode, and multi-hack
since I upgraded those.
And didn't I...
Yeah, I added...
Or rather, I included a new mod space.
So...
We have extended breach where the enemies stay open longer.
We have the hacking range, which is huge.
I'm not getting rid of that.
the speed of repair and boost their effectiveness we have
recursive learning increases hacking gauge build up by 15
when successfully completing a hack reduces damage received
by 20 when aiming with your weapon that's kind of nice too i
feel like usually i'm good at dodging but if i'm like being
greedy and aiming then i act i'm that's when i usually get
hit can you imagine living on kind of stuff i i can't
imagine living on the moon i can't imagine that at all 10
extra filament sounds good one second sounds
lonely it does seem kind of lonely one second one second
sorry
i don't know let's see what else i have increase max hp 10
more Luna filament.
Increases attack power by 10% within 10 meters.
At least we have close and long.
Chargeable weapons charge 30% faster.
Reduces damage by 20% when your HP is below 50.
Deal 10% more weapon or hacking damage against downed or
immobilized.
Immobilized?
Wait, if we were to have like, like use the lightning and
stuff, that's pretty good too.
Money.
More money, baby.
Let's try it.
Alright, I think we're good then.
To the Tarot!
Oh, oh.
This one.
Greed wins again.
They are working towards an actual moon base right now, I
think.
Wait, really?
Who will be the first one?
the first VTuber on the moon.
Who will be the first VTuber on the moon?
Nice.
Sometimes the jump feels like a little aggressive.
Sometimes I just want to hop.
I don't want to jump jump, you know?
Alrighty!
Oh, I see it!
Pretty, like...
Okay.
Here we go!
Oh no.
Is there like friendly buyer on this guy?
Oh shoot!
Oh my god I did not see him.
Okay let's uh...
Let's do this.
Oh wait.
He's right here?
Step off, buddy.
Uh, oh, wait.
I messed up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
I messed up.
I wasted precious time.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, he took that other guy with him.
Almost.
I just hate this.
Okay.
Move, you?
Move?
Oh.
All right, now that we just have the one guy, and maybe
we'll be okay.
Oh.
Blinking with the enemy.
Yes, it's my turn.
You?
I'm trying.
He's just sitting behind me.
Whoop.
Oh, shoot.
That's not what I meant to do.
Woo!
I meant to do more damage.
Just keep going, just keep going, just keep going, just keep
going, just keep going.
Oh!
What?
Go, go!
Take this!
Thank goodness we're red circles.
For real.
I feel like that didn't do so much, though.
Sip on the Hydra's back!
Alright.
Right on.
Is there more?
Oh, there are more guns.
Okay, cool.
piercer.
Whee!
Don't do it.
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
It's too hard here.
That's too hard with, like, this guy.
I feel like maybe he moves around too much.
Oh, maybe I can do it here.
Oh, no!
He turns too fast.
There's nowhere to be joking.
There's other weapons.
Oh, charge cursor.
Shockwave, there we go.
Yeah, we'll switch to that.
Oh, the lightning!
Oh my gosh, the lightning!
Came back!
I don't even notice.
Yeah!
Wait, maybe I can.
Ah, ah.
I was able to get one shot in at least.
Nice!
Oh nice
Not shoot now Oh shoot
Wait what did I oh okay That works too I accidentally
pressed that I guess I didn't realize that I pressed that
That's okay though
My goodness Can you turn around please I like doing anything
there.
Oh.
Oh my god, turn around, please.
Ah, I can't see.
I missed my chance.
Oh, please.
I need to get your back.
Nice, there we go.
Oh,
nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
He's booty shy, yeah.
3,000.
That's so mean.
Game?
It ate some of it, though.
Yes.
Just a little bit more.
Oh yeah!
That was
close.
Yeah!
Just a little bit more, just a tiny bit, the tiniest bit.
He is so stubborn!
Oh my goodness.
Holy cow.
That was...
You're going down.
Oh my goodness.
Ready?
Oh!
Yay!
Oh, that's... oh, blue.
Charge, piercer, charge piercer.
Use this when you're ready for some heavy high.
We'll just take everything.
What's this?
Data shard.
Minto gaming?
There it is.
Give me my money.
Where did I, I came in from there?
Can we go this one?
I think, yeah.
Glad that's over.
Me too.
We still gotta reboot that regulator, Hugh.
Oh yeah.
Pure Luna.
Nice.
I think over.
This is a fake wall.
I know it.
I know.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, there we go.
Strong soldiers.
Phew, that was close.
Did that sector guard get a new update or something?
I was just passing through like always, and it called me an
intruder and pointed its gun at me.
Who's tuning the sensitivity on these things?
I managed to lose it behind my hollow wall, but geez.
Wait, so he was even going after the scientists?
Our bot division sure has been ramping up heavy duty
munition testing over the last few months.
I get that demand is high and the top brass don't care what
I think, but it always ends up devolving into the same
boring Conversation about sacrificing performance for cost
cuts and so-called versatility Fate Explorer welcome back.
Thank you
At least the sector guards have a kind of heroic design
philosophy that I can actually get behind There's just
something thrilling about its overblown towering silhouette
Maybe I'm just a weirdo or something, but I'd rather people
saw these things as strong soldiers than as scary weapons.
Sharon is going on to create the Metal Gear.
Sharon!
Sharon, you're in the wrong universe!
Sharon, you would love Metal Gear!
I'm also gonna heal before I do so much more, too.
Yeah, Sharon and...
Sharon needs to switch spots, switch places with Otacon.
Wait, will this open?
No, okay.
Not yet.
Can we trade Sharon with Naomi?
MGS's Metal Gear Sharon!
Wait, what just happened?
You'd gain an additional weapon slot!
You can freely switch between weapons at any time!
Now you can hold more units!
Whew, won't say no to that.
That's crazy!
Wait, where the heck Where the key am I?
Oh, this did open.
Okay, good.
Whoa!
Nice.
Of all the places to put this thing.
For real.
So there's three of these?
Oh, okay.
There's still one more left.
There's...
Okay.
We got the first one, technically.
When we first came in.
Got it.
what just happened well done oh the other regulator is in
the next sector got it Diana we're out of here Diana that's
me you thought of it I see be careful Diana yeah this game
does like threes it does it'll be like yeah you have to go
to this first and this second what do we have We can't
really upgrade our suit or anything, but we can buy stuff.
And money is power, baby.
Rule of three is a classic for a reason, that's so true.
Money is power!
Da-da-da!
What have you been up to, Hugh?
Not much.
How about Hugh?
Get it?
Like, how about you, but instead it's Hugh?
All right, all right.
We could do our repair up or we could do the shock...
Wait, or the decoy gun.
The decoy generator.
I've got to do the decoy generator.
Upgrade a weapon using pure lunum.
Oh, neat.
Explain it again.
I didn't get it.
Look, there's even balloons here.
I just noticed.
That's too cute.
what's on TV oh yeah Gemini girls I made it back in time for
what's wrong what's up if we reboot one more limb regulator
the tree will disappear yeah man I hope the other regulators
easier to find I agree why'd they have to shove it in the
middle of nowhere yeah it's more fun that way you call that
fun running around looking for those things yeah it's the
best we've seen all kinds of There's no animals.
What's the point of nature without animals?
It's so fun talking to you, Hugh.
Aww.
Wait, just a few seconds.
Oh.
Now look.
Is this a princess?
A princess?
No, it's me wearing pretty clothes.
I want to wear something like this one day.
Wait, we can make her wear the cat outfit.
And I wanted to give this to you so you'd remember.
Wait, we can give her the cat outfit, though.
Maybe there's something in stock.
Yeah, yeah.
She wants to wear the cat outfit.
It's not my favorite, but it's still very, very cute.
Now I'm ready to go.
Now you're ready to go.
Let's go then.
Okie dokie.
I think we're okay.
Well, I guess we can do an extra weapon, though.
That's crazy.
Let's do this.
The sticky bombs.
Princess Diana outfit.
She looks so pretty though.
With her hair up and everything.
Yeah.
She is so precious.
Okay.
Now we're just a pair of cats on the moon.
Oh my gosh.
Well we're going to go see eight.
So it's perfect.
There's so much that we haven't gotten.
What?
Wait, what is... Wait, there's so much on the Terra Dome
platform that we haven't gotten.
It looks too warm for the season.
The danger area.
Oh, that's true.
We missed that.
Okay.
Wait, it's okay.
We'll just get what we can get and then...
So we went to there.
Did that cat just yawn?
Did you just yawn?
You sleepy.
Be careful, Hugh.
Oh.
While I'm trying.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Jump, Hugh!
Get ready!
Now!
Yeah!
Let's do this!
Wait, he's so close to dying, please!
Oh, oops.
There's more.
Oh, you mean like him?
Yeah, he's still around.
Yay!
Now it's my turn.
Oh, shoot.
That was so awkward.
I spent too much time trying to open it up.
The decoy gun is actually busted.
It's so good.
We love decoy gun.
How's fatherhood so far?
It's tough.
he's telling me how to live my life, how to take care of my
daughter.
Oh.
What if I just want a space ice cream?
Warning.
Clean room usage.
Research on self-growing saplings is in progress beyond this
point.
As you know, the plant factory is developing plants that
continue to grow after printing, adapting naturally to their
environment.
These saplings are extremely delicate.
So contamination of the subjects must be avoided at all
costs.
All visitors entering the clean room must pass through
decontamination room A or B first.
Decontamination cannot be skipped.
But you may choose either room freely.
Well, that's kind of strange.
So we've got to go through A or B if we want to continue.
Yes.
Just pick one, right?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
What's the difference between A or B?
Wait, is that the thing right there?
Ooh.
Wait, but these are not real plants.
That's just so funny.
Cultivation test in progress.
Evaluations are underway to identify the optimal
configuration of existing bots for fully automated
cultivation operations.
There's two walkers and one impeter.
Wait, isn't that what I just went through?
Two watchers and two impeters.
Wait, they tell you what's in here.
That's kind of nice.
So whether you want to go to A or B.
What's an impeter and what's...
Wait, is the walker literally...
Wait, is this one literally just what I went through?
I feel like, maybe?
The impeter, I think, is the guy with the katana, right?
The weeaboo.
Walker is basic humanoid model Oh really?
What's a watcher?
Let's go through this one.
It's the one that makes blue circles.
Oh I see.
I don't see.
Holy cow.
Oh!
oh that's a oh this is the mark 2 version the red god oh he
runs he runs he runs oh shoot uh
they're fast oh my gosh they're fast okay maybe i don't want
walker mark 2 they're scary
yeah get his booty
Don't panic.
Confuse.
We can use this as a distraction.
Yeah, that's good.
That's fine.
Everything's fine.
Let's see.
We can have crushers in Peter.
Okay, so in Peter was that thing.
Okay, got it.
I'm sure both will have stuff we can use.
They're faster, but low health.
Spitter!
An impeter.
One spitter?
Wait, what was this one again?
The right side has a chest?
It's not?
Wait.
But also this.
No turning back now.
Ah.
Rude.
Like...
I think they made the harder one.
Hold on, guys.
I have to go use the little gold.
ghosty's room.
I think they put the harder one on the right and then put
the better loot there too.
Oh, thank you so much for the read the record.
One second.
I've got to go to the ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I'm also grabbing more water.
One second.
I'll be right back again.
Oh my gosh.
I was like, my maid cafe is so toasty today.
Why?
And then I went and I forgot to turn the air on And it said
it was 78 degrees.
I was like, dang!
It's...
Maybe I'm just gaming.
Because it's toasty!
Oopsie!
Okay, hold on.
Let me go get some water.
Yucky.
I don't remember what was on this side.
78 is toasty.
Endorsed, yeah.
It was pretty...
Wait, no air on me or nothing.
Pretty, pretty toasty.
We'll get my decoy up and ready.
Over there!
Hello?
Oh yeah!
Oh now he might actually also...
Oh shoot!
Hey!
You're supposed to...
Wait.
Oops, I did that wrong.
You're supposed to go after the other guy.
Not me.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to go after me.
Oh.
The decoy is so good.
I'm glad I got the extended time one, too.
Also, that laser was just like...
You better not be jumping.
That's so mean.
More decoy!
No, he doesn't say F off, but it's really misleading, right?
It sounds like he's saying it so bad.
Two upgrade components.
Hmm.
I guess I won't be so mad at you for now, game.
Might be some good stuff in there.
If you're up for the challenge, Wait, why can't I go over
here?
That's so lame.
Is there a way to turn it off?
No?
Is this the red room?
Lancer.
Spitter.
He says PG-13 words because Diana.
He says something else, but it definitely...
Oh, yeah, step off.
It definitely sounds like F off for real.
It sounds like it's...
so much.
Well, this is the one we have to go to, I suppose.
Crusher 2?
Crusher Mark 2 2.
Oh, so the two... Oh my gosh.
Wait a second.
This is gonna be scary.
Two red guys and two big guys.
Mark 2 2.
I think you need the red room for the bingo You do, but...
I just don't...
I want to kind of get through the game a bit more right now,
rather than some of the other stuff.
So, we can always come back to do...
to do red room things.
Which...
I'll probably have to go through this again, huh?
Won't I?
They're gonna make me...
At least go through side A.
Oh wait, wait, did I go A first or B?
I think I did A.
And then B.
The red room dumps you out at the objective.
Wait, it does.
What does it have again?
Why does two lancers and one spider sound not so bad?
Like, why does that sound easier than this?
You know what I mean?
If you have to do it twice, you want all loot anyway, I
think.
Yeah, so true.
Yeah, it's suspiciously easy sounding.
You're right.
What am I looking at with my supplies?
I might need to switch to the sticky bomb.
I don't know.
Sticky bombs don't sound so great with...
What is this?
Oh, no, no, no.
Lots of lasers, maybe?
Maybe.
If I die, I don't know where it will put me back.
Let's try it anyway.
Let's challenge ourselves, everybody.
And I do have a decoy.
Is this the right way?
Guess we'll find out.
No clue.
What's this?
Oh, the printer!
What?
One-use printer.
That's craziness.
Good luck.
Yeah, I guess.
I mean, I'll need it, probably.
Oh my gosh.
I have to hopscotch.
I have to hopscotch with it.
Okay.
If I can get, like, one of these guys, you know?
Before.
Ugh.
I hear you.
I hear it counting down.
Okay, that's one guy at least.
Oh, shoot.
It's not.
He's not down yet.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh,
shit.
No.
Ah.
I'm, like, kind of getting lost in the sauce with it all.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
We're fine, maybe.
Oh.
I thought I had him down.
Uh-oh.
Woo!
Ouch!
Keep
the shooting to me!
Oh!
Did it.
Holy cow!
Oh, there was another decoy!
Oops.
Is that it?
Is that really it?
No.
This place has got some useful stuff.
They're doing another...
Wait, they're doing another unit printer.
That's not good.
Good job, Hugh.
Oh, thank you.
There's another printer, though.
Ah.
Oh.
Don't forget about overdrive.
You're right, you're right.
Thank you.
Thanks for the reminder.
Look, they give you weapons over there!
I have two more decoys again.
And decoys are great.
Holy cow.
This room looks actually like insanity.
What the hell is this?
What is this?
You can't be for real right now.
This will turn the bots against each other.
Shoot.
Oh, I got a high energy capacitor.
What the heck does that mean?
It means his attacks might be bigger.
Well, why did he say that earlier?
Oh, oh, I probably should have locked up.
That's so funny.
We'll just keep going like this for now?
Yeah?
What are you saying, Hewport?
We're just going for now?
Oh, shoot.
Yay!
Don't go inside the circle!
What circle?
Oh, okay.
Get out!
Don't go inside the circle!
Oh, uh...
Whatever.
Seems to be working?
It's so good.
I love decoy!
We're gonna need it again though.
Yeah, fight!
Fight!
Oh shoot, why are you coming after me?
Don't come after me!
Oh, oops, that's not what I meant to do.
Uh...
Oh,
they're going.
They're confused.
Nice!
Yeah, confusion, confusion.
They're all confused.
They have no idea.
I don't think he's confused anymore.
Or something.
Oh, geez!
Uh-oh.
Then my decoys are... Go away!
I
think that might be our confused guy though.
We might want to...
Wait, I can't tell who's confused anymore.
I don't know.
I've lost all track!
Okay, we at least got that guy.
It's a lot of robots.
It is.
Hey, John, hate this!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Awesome.
Hey.
Oh, I don't even need to do that.
No, stinking way.
They said here's another decoy generator.
You're a winner.
Oh.
Sure.
I'll take whatever I can get.
Help!
Oh dear.
They look like family.
Probably a buck and his phone.
So their DNA is a 50% match.
Well, a family isn't just what's in your DNA.
Well, the DNA is also the memes.
Not at all.
I mean, I was adopted.
Adopted?
Yeah.
When a family takes you in as their own.
Even though we don't share the same dna they're still my
family oh and i love them oh
tuna i hear something for sure
oh this guy what's wrong with him additional data left over
on a training simulation terminal the data will be sent to
the shelter oh this is training there's a broken cabin here
maybe that's their training simulation data oh poor little
guy increases attack power by 15 when attacking enemies from
behind cheap shot damage when you hit weak points
emergency response manual plants inside the terra dome are
monitored by dedicated regulators in each area which will
automatically shut down in the event of a problem after
resolving the issue the regulators and perform an error
check.
Regulators can be linked together, but if the system is
offline, each must be restarted manually.
Oh, that's where...
Almost forgot about the limb regulator.
No.
Then we take the limb to go see 8, right?
Yeah.
There's so much stuff over there.
Why is he acting like that?
What do you mean?
We'll do what...
Yes, that's what we're doing.
No, we're doing all this so we can take the...
Ooh.
Look.
A new unit.
Pulse carbine.
Easy to use and capable of fully automatic fire.
This rifle prioritizes speed over power.
Hitting enemy weak points will slightly increase heat
buildup.
Burst fire.
Ammo will replenish automatically.
Oh!
We have a new...
New primary!
That's huge!
I thought this was like a purse of...
Okay, I thought it was like a person.
Like kind of their head and their hands on the table.
You know?
Like reaching for the weapon or something.
Wait, is there more?
Oh.
Delphi sure didn't skimp on security.
Oh, I've been saying Delphi.
Delphi.
Oops.
That one was much faster than the first one.
Because the first one involves so much more like
exploration.
How do I get over there?
Wait.
Just as I did, baby.
These pretty plants can be found growing all over forest or
fields.
They can be easily plucked with a light pole.
They're fragile, so handle with care.
I wonder what that...
Oh, nice fine.
Ah, you've made it.
do.
You've stumbled upon our top-secret Terra Dome Hanami Club!
Once the Luna Filament Cherry Tree has reached perfection,
we will gather here with our finest sake to celebrate.
Since you've discovered our hidden spot, consider yourself
invited.
Leave your drinkable cleaning fluid at the door.
This is your shot to taste real booze.
Reach out if you dare.
Isamu Club President.
Yes.
Oh, Hanami.
It's a Japan thing, I think.
You think?
What's that?
A bunch of people under a cherry tree having a good old
time.
Whoa, that sounds like...
Ah, yes.
Japan thing.
They said it's a secret club, though.
Our club's not allowed.
Our club's like sort of, uh...
Looked frowned upon, you know?
They're like, oh no, you weirdos making a club.
The people yearn for...
before uh i want to whoa sorry i wanted to see how that
worked wait a second i can't change my primary anymore it's
one or the other no wait
that's kind of icky gotta go back to base to decide oh man
We will go back to base just because.
Robots killed everyone because they couldn't find the clone.
Oh, the clone.
Everybody's getting funky in the clone.
Fantastic.
Mr. Fox, welcome back.
Thank you!
So, what should we do?
Let's plant flowers.
We rebooted both the regulators.
Give it a present.
Clue.
Flowers.
Were these the ones from the Terra Dome?
Mm-hmm.
And she doesn't care.
Diana!
We rebooted.
I'm glad all the trees didn't go away.
Didn't take you for the tree-hugging type.
The Terra Dome would be so empty without them.
It would.
But what good's a place like that?
without some green in it yeah filament eraser huh pretty
cool that you get new ability yeah I know I'm so happy I
can't wait till we get the red one too even more than before
I'm counting on you she's gonna eat oh you the new powers
remember when I said you're useful huh oh yeah you're more
than that um hmm I can't really find the words but I feel
like we gotta stick together always that so glad I live up
to your expectations we're in this together kiddo
there's still this one here which I believe is also probably
the one in the Terra Dome or maybe it's still over there as
well who knows oh I can't wait to see the forest or whatever
gets created here Let's see We got a new Luna filament so we
can either Upgrade our shockwave gun Which I use a ton I
love this guy Um Or we can upgrade our repair I'm feeling
more the shockwave gun I'm feeling more Upgrade the
shockwave gun Probably
Oh my god Oh my god sticky bombs rapid fire recoil ammo
capacity rapid fire
and then let's do
whoa oh i'm just now looking at this thing it's huge the
best defense is good offense so true
Um, let's do...
Yeah, the carryover...
I guess because it says primary unit rather than the actual
gun that it is.
We'll do a...
We could also...
Do our suit, which is more defense, but it's like barely any
more defense.
We go from 1.08 to 1.09.
I don't honestly know what that means.
what that means quite very much but i think we'll do our
primary unit and then we can do our suit next time oh hello
oh yeah we have the new new training new training simulation
stop and go reach the target in 65 seconds you could get
four upgrade components if we completed in 55 seconds Medic,
defeat all enemies.
If we do these...
We would be able to upgrade.
Let's try this.
Let's try...
This.
I don't know if I'll make it, but if I do...
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay!
Oopsie.
Well, why did it do that?
Okay, I'm gonna...
We're gonna do that another day.
It's just green light.
Yeah, it's just green light, green light.
We'll come back to that.
I actually do want to go do to the cat.
I want to go to the cat.
The cheap shot.
That's right, we got that one.
Um...
My nodes.
Rip gun.
Wait a second.
Was it eight before or was it seven?
I can't remember.
Riot blaster.
Techie ball.
Charge piercer.
No, I like the shockwave gun.
And charge piercer there.
Decoy.
to place multi-hack and then also uh decode and also
confused pretty good
she's curious oh she looking at the balloons wait what's she
looking at the balloons out will they pop she's looking at
the balloons yeah problem for a future made mental so true
Alright, back to the Terra Dome.
What did we miss on the platform?
I'm so curious.
It didn't feel like there was so much around.
But now I'm like, what did we miss?
Confused plus multi-hack is strong because it confuses all
of them if you combine them?
No way I had no clue about that.
That's huge.
I love how they're basically like little Pokemon.
views and it was highly effective so we need to protect
Diana with all your strength I am could she be the scientist
that made you I don't think so do you remember something no
it's not that I I just feel like she's someone important to
me I see we could fall here be careful we better step on it
we could fall there be careful oh there's the other one the
other red room wait how many red rooms are in here should we
take a break
wait no this is not a red room it just says lockdown just
kidding abs always be scanning you're right
you were so right oh use your arms thank you
Vision shot.
Activating fast moves successfully starts a period of
slowdown where weapon damage increases by 10%.
Oh.
Aha!
I knew there was going to be something over here.
I had a feeling.
I knew it.
I said there must be something behind that.
That's why I started climbing up the big roof earlier.
Wait.
She looks just like Diana.
Diana, you're here.
Thank you.
Wait.
Tree, baby.
So you're eight.
What on earth happened here?
Wow, I was preparing to depart for earth.
The moon quake struck.
Oh, so Diana, there's more than one Diana.
Yeah, another Prague model.
The bots, these trees, everything went out.
of control you can see how well I fared oh the claws are
killing me they look like I lost my team they look like like
his nails are done if we can access the mainframe we could
force Edis offline with this stop code as pragmatic we're
equipped with the ability to overwrite a systems programming
that's same power lies within you Diana there's nothing like
that in my memory I see how unfortunate no well let's see
what we can do about that tree yeah yeah
go John Halo I'm sorry I have no help that's not true you've
made it this way far haven't you she looks like a cozy comfy
bear from behind soil doesn't look like we can do anything
here but there's another place we can check well the place
we just shut eat us down and then we'll head to earth hold
on eight we'll get you out of there thank you
meet the trapped girl twins another prongada what's up 8
sure seem driven yeah not sure why she wants to go to earth
but guess that'll come after we bust her out should be
another regulator down below when I can clear that tree
let's go find it yes it's like it feels like one of the
situations where like I'm the robot that's programmed to be
goofy and I'm the robot that's programmed to be serious you
know what I mean I'm the seriously I'm the serious built
with a purpose robot.
And I'm the robot that's built to be a silly goose.
Oh, kind of spooky.
I hear like...
It sounds like maybe frogs, but it's weird not hearing like
crickets and stuff, you know.
Fake frog.
Bright.
There's some over here.
I will 3D print a frog.
Oh, and we'll like that!
I just noticed we have three cabin coins.
There was one up here, it said.
No?
23 meters.
It says I'm so close.
But it's like below me.
Eh?
Hmm.
I would 3D print a frog.
I think we can go up here.
No, we can't.
No.
Oh, up there.
I can hear the sound of waves.
Waves?
Hold on.
I must, I must...
Perhaps that's where we fall.
Wow!
I'm actually geese are mean and terrifying.
silly about them yeah i went after a goose yesterday and he
hissed at me but he was all by himself and i felt so bad i
was like you're a little goose you're a little goose anyway
yeah simulations
are beautiful simulated water oh you've been to the sea
before on earth of course i have got a house with a view oh
she's doing the same thing she's trying a house she's We'd
head down to the water anytime we felt like taking a break
from it all.
Ocean breeze does a number on the paint, but still.
A breeze in the paint?
It'll make sense when you see it.
You know, back on Earth.
You're just gonna stay here when this is all done.
What do you want?
I want To go to Earth With you Can I really go?
Then I can go see your house And the ocean Oh no You bet
This feels like a flag This feels like such a flag No
they're not going to do anything to the child Okay But we
got to help 8 first But you!
Oh no.
And then we can all go to Earth together!
No.
This feels like a...
Oh.
Oh!
I wouldn't say a red flag.
Maybe a death flag.
Let's finish this.
Oh geez.
Right.
Oh.
Oh, I guess we could go down there.
Oh, spooky.
Oh, I don't like that.
Get me out of here.
I don't like that one bit.
One bitty bit at all.
Wait, can we go into the ocean?
Oh, no, it won't land right here.
What about this ocean?
Bamito, the loot.
There's something here!
I lied.
Oh, is this where I need to go?
Okay, let's go into the darkness.
Become a Lou Goblin.
I am!
But I'm also afraid.
Oh, when you have to turn on the flashlight, it's...
Oh, it's a training simulation.
More training data.
Can't wait to try that in training sim.
Routine check report.
All sectors of the Terra don't remain fully operational and
construction of the new area is proceeding on schedule.
Maybe the subversion is that it actually works out, right?
Please?
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll all make it to Earth.
Well, I'll make it to Earth.
with routine tasks now handled by bots human cause delays
have been eliminated smooth sailing note the system
inspection noted an unrecognized admin level update to Edis
I don't know the ending at all but that scene raised so many
red flags it made me sad but it's so beautiful I know that's
exactly how I feel it was so beautiful but I'm so sad but it
was so beautiful but I'm so sad possibly authorized by earth
HQ I'll follow up in the next routine briefing.
What the heck?
Unrecognized admin level update to Edis?
Changing the admin access level on Edis?
Is that even possible?
I think there's...
Oh.
We'll swap.
I like this a bunch of security.
Stop it.
Well, like anyone could get past all that.
Oh, this just shows you that...
I think when you go inside, this just shows you that there
was this area, I think.
Um...
This area is so beautiful.
I want to go to the beach.
Look, you can see the projectors.
That's so funny.
What does that say?
Max cargo.
Wait, there's a viewing area!
We have to go up there!
We have to go up to the viewing area.
Wait, can I climb these rocks?
Let me climb these rocks.
Okay.
Gamer looked up.
She did it.
We have reached.
A new level.
Another damn locked door.
Oh, wow.
Oh, it is really locked, huh?
There's one.
Wait, is this another one right here?
Oh, it is.
That's two.
That's two?
Two more to go, right?
Maybe we should hire our own to do this for us is this not
our own bot to do this for us the one that oh godly wait a
second hold on i'm not done up here though the bot that
we're currently using is not our own bot to do this i hate
when window updates you to install the evil patch wait
what's happening when an enemy's heat gauge is full it will
be knocked down down enemies can be hit with critical shot
from a close range.
Oh, I think this is what I did earlier.
The heat gauge fills when enemies are shot or successfully
hacked, but it gradually decreases when they're left alone.
Uh, oh!
In-yew!
This gun is good at building up that gauge.
Oh, nice.
I guess because it's like, uh...
It's like, uh...
What's the word?
Oh.
slower using gun.
One second.
We have to go back.
To here.
Maybe I can climb up.
This.
I am monkey.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, see?
I told you it was to jump down rather than jump up.
I am monkey.
Oh, hello.
Is that big guy right there?
repair kit oh geez guys I'm starting to get super hungry oh
there's us oh why did I climb up there I'll do that I'm
starting to get hungry maybe my tea is making me I
got the wrong guy let's
also get this guy while we have him be careful New weapon.
Oh, photon laser!
Powerful attack unit that shoots a concentrated photon beam.
Mobility is reduced while firing, but its damage increases
the longer the beam is sustained.
Where'd he go?
Wait, where'd he go?
Where'd that guy go?
Oh, here he is.
He doesn't
see me at all, he's so stupid.
Wait, he's...
What an idiot.
Aw man.
Check.
Take this!
My my beam!
I was so...
I'm glad that these ones are at least pretty easy.
These guys are pretty... not so bad.
Puss!
I need you to reload faster, man, please.
Octopus!
Oh, that was freaky.
Oh, these ones are so annoying, are they?
Oh, there's a... I just noticed that.
And there's three!
Nice!
One more to go!
Just one more!
I'd love to talk to the brain that scattered all these
terminals around.
That's a great question, honestly.
Like...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Boy, don't...
Got him?
Oh, another.
Having higher capacity is so nice sometimes.
Oh, Tuna?
I see him.
Thank you.
Toona.
Whoa.
Can't believe she did this in reverse.
Oh.
Wait.
Is there supposed to be a thing here that makes me go up?
What?
What do you mean in reverse?
That makes more sense from...
Wait.
Oh, that's an elevator!
Oh.
Oh!
You're supposed to take the elevator here!
My bad.
Well...
Let's go back down, I guess.
Wait, and then I'm gonna have to come all the way back up
and then go all the way.
I thought I heard something walking.
Well, it's fine!
Oh, I messed up.
I messed up bad.
Well, it's fine.
I...
There we go.
Layside.
Getting to fight on the beach is cool.
Yeah?
Oh, hold on.
I need a snack.
I have some chippies here.
Wait, also.
I got pocky.
There was like a sale.
I got some pocky.
What kind of chips?
Veggie chips?
Girl dinner.
Basically.
Okay, I got it.
Yes.
Whoever...
uh uh not the word sacrifice is not the word whoever was
just like oh whoever left the offering of pocky said that
they were on sale so thank
you for the year thank you you
can't hear can you can't hear can you sorry i felt i felt
myself starting to lose my brain
you can okay that's why i'm here
it's fine okay i'm sorry i just need like
break now I was losing my brain it started oozing out of my
ears I
like how it says it's worth here but it's all question marks
now my look up
One nice pocky.
Do you want some pocky?
You take the other side?
Just kidding.
I want it.
I'm too hungry to share.
Minto eating animation.
is the cutest thing in the universe.
What are you talking about?
Nothing to- AHHHHH!
I thought I was coming from the ceiling.
That's where we were before.
Oh, I hear him.
Where'd he go?
I know you're octopus.
Oh.
Oh, oops, that's not what I meant to do.
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Come on
Yeah Okay
Maybe I shouldn't have used my gun Maybe I should have used
the final attack But that's fine I Hocked this thing And it
worked Yippee Oh Oh they give me another photon gun Oh Oh
Maybe Keep that laser shooting for continuous damage.
Maybe not the smartest.
Oh, that's it.
Yahoo!
Let's go.
Let's go back all the way.
Surprise they haven't grabbed you yet.
Good job.
I might be a gamer.
Now this path is clear and it's nice and cozy.
Wait.
I would no no not with the window I said I wanted to go all
the way from the viewing deck and I didn't even view
what wow
this reminds me of something I can't say yet though my
secret project this reminds me of my secret project I'm
gonna have another pocky they're so yummy I love weeaboos
thanks for making pocky popular
you're welcome
it's just the perfect ratio of chocolate and i'm missing a
box of chocolate and biscuit so delicious i'm a big fan but
i'm missing a box it was like so close just next to us.
22, 21, 20, 19, 18, 17, 16, 14, 13, 12, 11.
Where?
Hey, where?
I thought I got the one on the ledge.
There's another one on the ledge that I missed.
Drop down from above again.
My gob went up there though, didn't I?
Or maybe I forgot it too.
Wow, it's so pretty.
It's too pretty.
And then, oh, never mind.
That was that window.
Wait, oh, sorry, I passed it.
Maybe I saw it and thought I got it and didn't get it.
Maybe I think that's what happened with me.
Because I definitely saw...
No, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, I definitely did not see this.
I'm a big phony.
I'm a big fat liar.
That's a lot of limb.
Yeah, baby.
Alright, nice.
And then there's another one down below.
That we missed.
Let me go back down, sorry.
I am being a bit of a loot goblin now.
Before we go inside.
And face what I...
I thought I heard second pair of footsteps.
What I assume will be a boss.
Scary.
There's so many boxes.
Wait.
We have a fake wall?
Hmm.
I give up for now.
for now maybe it's actually also getting stuff behind this
door now that I think about it no definitely not but I don't
know at all fake wall in the tunnel up it's gotta be
something right maybe where the light is flickering
wait what's that did we go there before
did we use this already oh yeah I think that was to this one
yeah that's to this guy so I don't know
it's weird because they say they're all like it says I'm
getting further Now I'm getting closer.
But it's behind me?
It's so confused!
I'm very confused.
I need to look up.
Wait, I wonder if it's up there.
Is it up in the walls?
Or the ceiling?
Is there like a piece that's broken and I can jump into it?
I'm confused.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I give up for real I tried like Oh
Oh that's just a reflection I thought it was a hidden wall
Can the hidden walls be Rock
Gotta go up to find it Mysterious Too mysterious Let's just
grab this for now
Oh my god We found you Nah nothing else in here though how
lame hmm what is this signal interference
protection to safeguard sensitive experiments conducted in
the Terra Dome we're testing a system that uses high-tech
jamming devices to block out black outside radio
interference the jamming signal blocks incoming interference
for a limited time preventing not only on unauthorized
access but also forced intrusions like hacking how do they
know what that is is please note that wireless devices will
also be disabled so exercise caution when activating the
system aha what am i supposed to do if i can't hack what do
you want me to do wait a second oh i thought this was like
lighting up i saw like the blue lights and i thought it was
lighting up like a fake wall hold on i'm gonna give one more
look The issue is, is like...
Going, you know, like...
What's the word?
You can't just follow it.
Was that me?
That couldn't have been me.
That sounded like someone walking.
For real.
Wait.
I see a hidden wall.
Right here.
That's not a hidden wall!
I got decoy octopus.
We did it.
I heard the steps.
I heard the footsteps.
I even said I was like, I think those are footsteps.
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
I think those are footsteps.
I said so.
And he still didn't help me.
I mean, it wouldn't have made sense because I saw what that
wall looked like.
I know what it looks like here.
It's all blown.
locked off.
I don't know.
Maybe I thought, like, it could be another room.
Who knows?
I don't know.
If anyone knows, I'll take hints, but I do actually.
Actually, I like finding these on my own.
But I'm pretty stumped by this.
Here?
I'm so stumped.
No elf.
Okay.
Yeah, I get it.
You're good.
Pretty sure all the stuff you're scanning is just ahead of
you.
Take the elevator.
I don't think so.
But I was going to take the elevator anyway.
Oh, wait.
How much stuff do I have to upgrade?
We can upgrade.
More chippies.
Oh, I thought the elevator was going out.
I guess if it's going down, it makes more sense.
You like that weapon, huh?
I stand corrected that.
The sea was so pretty.
I couldn't believe my eyes.
The sparkling water.
The gentle breeze.
You've really taken to the sea, huh?
That hologram back there was pretty good, but the real
thing's gonna blow you away.
That's only the beginning.
I'll take you all over, kiddo.
forward to.
Yay!
Oh, no.
Diana, have you ever had a dream?
I don't need sleep.
No.
I mean, have you ever wanted something to come true?
Oh, no.
Huh?
Like, a prediction?
I make those all the time.
Look at you, you little daydreamer.
Diana, do pragmatic grow like humans do?
I can learn things, but I won't get taller.
Also, my body was made with special components, so fixing me
isn't easy.
If you want a bigger pragmata, it would be more efficient to
start from scratch.
Wait, I thought she said that she could be fixed easily.
Or like...
Let's just drop it for now.
Wait, remember when she was chasing after the cat?
And she was like, oh, if I fall, you can just...
Lari-duni-mui, whatever.
Remember?
Hey.
go away it's sad right so are you still sad that Nicholas is
gone what do you think of course I'm sad look he didn't just
go away he's dead there's a difference there are all kinds
of goodbyes but losing someone to death that's the hardest
oh no oh god oh my god is she gonna how is she gonna learn
You getting along okay with that janky bop with the funny
dad hat?
They have a name, you know.
It's cabin.
They're like two peas in a pod.
They're really nice.
They call me Little One.
Little One?
They don't even call you by your name?
Oh.
So many flags, I know.
You ready to go?
Ready when you are.
Okay, we got all the dialogue.
Cool.
I'm scared for Hew.
Look at us.
We're all evenly leveled up.
So nice.
And symmetrical.
Unisca- Oh, nice.
We got the photon laser.
I'll just add that bad boy in.
Oh.
Oh, it's so crazy looking.
Okay.
Let's do...
Sorry, let's do Friendly the Confused.
And we'll do Decode again.
One second.
I got Chippy in my throat.
Okay.
That should be good.
Maybe we'll do more for the guns themselves after this.
But I feel like I...
Like, I mean, I guess I should upgrade them.
But I don't like using the charge piercer.
Photonizer we just got.
Stasis net is good.
Only thing is other the decoy generator that I like.
So it's kind of hard to say.
Oh!
New trainings?
No training simulations.
Along the boxes.
Reach target area.
Oh, it looks like things are fighting.
Oh, baby!
Defeat executor in 45 seconds.
Don't let enemies use antennas.
What's antennas?
Defeat all enemies.
Which is, yeah.
Complete within 30 seconds.
It's the baby.
Defeat enemies with weapons slash recycler.
Interesting.
Missed Wolf, happy birthday!
Day early, happy day, early birthday!
Let's see.
Let's do shock and photon.
And our hackings and our mods are good.
And we ride the train to the Terra Dome, to the Science Lab.
Wow, oh wait, I did get this.
Oh, there was nothing to get.
I was like, wow, I completed one.
Ikimasu.
There was nothing to get.
But there was!
There was that one box.
I guess it didn't count.
It didn't count.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
This goes down.
There we go.
It's kind of slow.
Oh.
What is that?
You?
That device is emitting some kind of jamming signal.
If we touch it, I won't be able to hack.
Damn.
And what the heck are we supposed to do?
Oh, ah!
Shoot.
What are we supposed to do?
Get rid of it?
I don't know.
I knew it.
I knew you were here.
Dad's room.
Terraforming Development Department prizes individual
research over teamwork, which means I get my own lab and
plenty of freedom.
I can rebuild my old house, recreate landmarks from around
the world, or even take a crack at replicating famous
forests and rivers.
That looks about right.
This used to be my dad's room.
I wanted to see if I could bring it back from memory.
When I was a kid, his technical manuals on gems and minerals
were more captivating than any picture book.
I guess you could say I was gifted.
I graduated college at 12, and by 15, my thesis had caught
the attention from Delphi.
That's how I got pulled into all of this.
As for my dad, I never heard a word from him.
two years ago.
He never really cared about me.
Not that I think he was intentionally cruel.
He just devoted himself to the things that fascinated him.
His child did not fascinate him.
His genius child.
Maybe in some ways I'm more like him than I ever realized.
Share it.
It's like so close to looking like a room and then you see
like the, you know, walls and everything.
What's that?
What are those?
Candies.
The wallpaper trees.
Yeah.
What is this?
Who's going to come out of there?
That's better.
Hmm.
Maybe when I open this.
More money!
Uh...
Oh, there is a door here.
The VTuber is blind.
I hear something walking.
I think I hear an octopus.
You hear it?
They're like kind of the only ones that really walk around,
you know?
That we know of.
Scary.
Why would there be an octopus here?
Because it's so fruitful.
I don't see him, though.
Oh, I see him.
Okay, never mind.
They're not that hard to see, luckily.
Come on.
Come here.
Come here, baby.
Oh, I got trapped by the...
the tree.
Oh.
I got to rip with a tree.
Who said, oh, I'm surprised you haven't.
Oh, come on.
I'm surprised you haven't gotten grabbed yet.
Oh, my God.
You jinxed me.
Whoever said that, you jinxed to me.
You jinxed to me.
Oh,
shoot.
Yeah.
I wonder when they're invisible, if you can get them by the
net.
But you need them to charge to be able to hack them.
So I don't think that's a great idea, to be honest.
You need them to come running at you to be able to get them.
Oh, nice.
Three upgrade components.
Very beautiful.
You can shoot them to take their visibility away?
Is it?
You think Ace Tree's gone now too?
I don't think so.
Seems like it only got rid of the trees in here.
What a flawed system this is.
It's so stupid.
Is this where we...
Oh.
Oh yes, we're gonna hide everything literally everywhere.
so that you can just struggle all the time.
Was there anything else in here?
Yeah, it's always a beast cannon!
I don't think so.
Probably...
Maybe enough.
Maybe.
Something this way.
Something that way.
Okay, whatever.
I guess that's where I'm supposed to go.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, this is evil.
Oh, geez.
It's right there.
Be careful.
Oh, it's only we had a unit that could delete nodes.
What do you mean by that?
What does that mean?
Oh!
Oh, it got jammed.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
You're fine, actually.
Yeah, you're going down, buddy.
You're going downtown.
Actually, I want to...
Overdrive Protocol at the rate.
Oh.
There we go.
Yeah.
Well, you sit there and think about what you've done.
Crack up.
What is this?
Stasis net.
Ah, okay.
Oh, I guess if we wanted to, like, keep it...
kind of like
if we wanted to keep it well I don't know actually
I don't know how like I'm trying to see how we would have
avoided the
it getting unable to be hacked because of the rings but if
it gets hot If it gets caught...
Oh, yeah, we do have more company!
Oh,
yeah, they're stupid.
Oh, yeah, they're all so dumb.
Look at them go.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
The last one's standing.
You're so strong!
Take this!
Stupid robots!
Oh!
Is there anything in here?
Aww.
Awesome!
So strong and so dead.
I didn't have to do nothing, I just stood there for the most
part.
It was great.
I was so comfortable.
The cradle is the product of a Delphi-led effort to
establish a hub for mining and research initiatives on the
moon.
Oh, okay, not yet.
Oh, okay.
Gotcha.
Like, by the way, super scary, evil, difficult area.
Let's see what's in here first.
Before we go do all of that fun stuff.
How do I open some of these doors?
Look, this is where they sleep and stuff.
What if somebody was like...
This is so...
2026!
It's real XD?
What?
It's real.
Well, imagine like you overslept and you wake up and all of
this has happened.
I heard you're transferring over to the Limp Lab.
Limp... Oh, that's...
I'm a little worried.
Why is that?
Weren't you angling to get into basic limnological research?
I'm happy about the reassignment, but I'm worried I might
struggle to keep up.
Oh, is that with Dr. Higgins?
I've memorized all the papers, but some of the stuff he
comes up with on the fly.
I wouldn't worry too much.
You're not the first researcher to have trouble keeping up
with the good doctor.
Dr. Higgins is a very special man.
it ready to learn
that sounds intimidating and terrifying there's rem data
nearby let's take it back to the shelter no kidding dr
higgins is a special guy hey yeah i work at hey i work at
hey how do i open you Hmm...
Why?
What was the point?
Oh!
Gamers don't look up.
What is this?
She looked up!
Let's go!
Tuna?
Tuna!
What do we get?
A swing!
They call her the gamer that looks up.
There he is!
Wait, look how cute he is.
Ta-da!
What is he saying?
Actually, there's no way he's not saying tuna.
He's saying ta-da?
Why is there so much emphasis?
on the two.
Ta-da!
It doesn't matter.
It's tuna now.
I can't hear anything other than tuna.
I know, me neither.
Tuna.
It's tuna and I will die on the hill.
Yeah.
He's just a little blot.
I love some maguro sushi.
Who doesn't?
Okie dokie.
Spooky scary room.
Hugh!
We got a security zone.
Yeah, we do.
How many mouse traps are they going to set for us?
That's...
I'm genuinely curious what...
And also how people get around this place.
Like...
How many...
Oh, there's so much on the ground.
Okay, wait.
Don't start yet.
I'm not ready.
Cabin coin.
I think Cabin will like that.
I think Cabin will like...
Oh.
Now we have to...
Now we have to go down.
Oh, well that sucks.
How do I get to the other side, though?
Hmm.
Why did the chicken cross the road?
Can I go back through?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Uh...
Decoy!
Jenkins
We're fine Have I been to that side?
Oh, that's, yes I have
I want that multi-hack Sorry guys, we're going back to get
that I just realized it was there
You can jump dash to the other platform too No
No!
Okay, never mind.
You can jump dash?
Okay, I'll try it.
That is so mean.
Oh!
Triple dash is great!
We have 11 now.
Nice.
There is something down... Oh, that's a...
thing about Bob the things that I just got alright I'm gonna
not be a chicken anymore decoy Jenkins
oh my god one of these things no stinking no stinking way
oh shoot okay we got it
Oh my gosh, wait, there's still jam- that one's not- ah,
it's still jammed, though.
We'll get confusion.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, uh, which- what's happening?
Uh, I think we need another-
another decoy for now.
Yeah, yeah, get those?
Okay, nice.
We'll just take this guy out when I can.
Be careful.
It's on now.
Okay.
It's my birthday!
Ryan, are you having fun?
Uh, can you, like, uh, friendly fire, please?
Actually, since I'm right here.
Nice.
Oh, that's it.
That's the way.
Ah, people!
Uh, shoot.
Oh no, I don't need you anymore.
I think he's the only one left.
Yeah.
Oh, I literally just got him in between the cheeks.
I got him in between the cheeks.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Yippee!
A second one!
Oh my god.
I went inside the circle.
That's so my bad.
Okay.
Uh, whoop.
Uh, what circle?
What circle?
Uh.
Overdrive?
Yeah, you're so right.
We have two of them.
We can overdrive for sure.
Yeah!
Oh, nice.
Good job, Katie.
Oh.
Uh.
Hold on, laser!
Oh, let's save it.
Uh.
Take this.
Yay!
Uh.
Where's the other guy?
Oh, he's just chilling.
Now it's my turn.
Oh, shit.
Uh.
Oh shoot.
Look
out!
Correct.
What's this right here?
I mean, I'll take it, but...
Probably not better than this one at the moment.
Careful!
It's going to jump!
Oh!
Whoa, my goodness.
Okay, buddy.
Oh, don't laser!
Don't go inside the circle!
Get up on the Hydra's back!
I don't like it.
What's this one?
Wait, Stasis net.
We can trap them.
Nyaha!
Stupid head.
Yeah.
I...
I got him!
Nyaha!
How you like this?
Yeah, how you like this?
It's going to jump!
Oh my goodness.
You're so tanky.
Stupid.
Yeah.
You guys might be upgrading their design.
They're definitely getting stronger.
I think that is probably maybe at the moment one of my
bigger...
Uh...
What's the word?
Well, okay, like...
What am I bigger?
It's not a complaint, but it's like when a game...
When a game...
Even like the regular walking guys, I don't mind the red
ones.
But like even the regular ones, I thought were taking more
hits than usual.
And I was like, oh...
Like why are they upgrading those guys as well?
Do you get what I mean?
we can use this to stop bots in their tracks no we'll do
that yeah it's like a pet peeve of mine it's like let the
weak enemies remain weak but like introduce new enemies you
know what I mean level scaling early game enemies yes that's
the word thank you sorry like I said my brain started
leaking out of my ears let's figure out how to get this guy
in here we could probably go probably have to go around for
him like I said I don't mind the red guys oh this opens back
up okay good oh it's like foggy in here it's freaky
is that door right there something
sounds too mysterious in here.
You know what I mean?
What box in here?
Yeah, the reskins, yeah, the red guys.
Yeah, I don't mind that at all.
I'm not saying like don't ever, you know, update the guys or
anything.
It's just like a you know.
Early enemies are early enemies.
And if you, if they come back, like have them come back in
swarms if you want to mega swarms if you want to have them
around still.
I don't know.
It's just my pet peeve with games sometimes.
I guess we do have to go through here.
Oh yeah.
You see that?
What?
See what?
Wait, how do I get in there?
Up.
Yeah, I give him a new move.
Yeah, something like that.
Okay, I think we go from maybe here.
here yeah there we go nice how do i get out of here did you
see it um actually i didn't i need i need a red circle i
need where's my gamer maybe we can upgrade our stuff i need
a gamer paint oh nice
Feels like it's lagging all of a sudden.
It was doing that the other day, too, when I was playing
off-stream.
I just started lagging all of a sudden.
Use your arms.
Hugh.
Hugh, use your arms.
Can we not...
We can go in here, no?
Use your arms!
Loading a new map.
My PC is...
My CPU is at, like, 85%.
87%.
83 87 100 32 57 yeah percent 93
no that's load the temperature was like still pretty high as
well though
Geoscience lab development plan it's at 44 degrees Celsius.
Oh, geez.
65 degrees Celsius.
Why is it jumping around so much?
Computer, are you okay?
It's toasty day outside.
Oh, my God.
70 degrees Celsius.
Let's go.
We are conducting tests with the newly developed Luna
filament plants to determine whether natural cycles can
proceed without interruption.
Okay.
You don't have to worry until it's like 80-90.
Okay, cool.
Sub 80 under load is nothing.
Standby period.
Until the eco-modeling lab and the plant factory achieve
certain research milestones, the facility will remain on
standby.
In the meantime, we continue to simulate future layouts,
blending conventional lunar filament plants with holograms,
testing how the ecosystem will thrive once full operations
begin.
This looks like there's probably an auction.
to press around.
If I had to guess.
Could be a freebie.
Oh, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh,
yeah, oh, yeah.
Hmm.
Okidoki, let's go up.
Oh, down.
Or let's go down.
I don't even have a key, I think.
Yeah.
Terrarium.
It sounds incredibly menacing.
Restricted area.
Authorized personnel only.
Do not enter.
Up for it.
CPU may be at 80%, but Minto Quito is at 120%.
Why is it so scary in here?
Whoa, what is this?
It's that black stuff from before.
Oh yeah.
Like back at the MPA.
This is way more than what we saw before.
It seems to be spreading.
Uh oh.
Whoa.
That's not good.
Must have been working on something special down here.
The couple, thank you.
Something special.
Oh no, the goop monster.
It looks so...
actually it looks really delicious anyone else thinking that
oh my god like look at that texture on it oh kind of yummy
maybe i'm just saying venom
i said what i said pterodome 2 suspension notice the planned
pterodome 2 facility on the lunar surface has been
indefinitely postponed to prioritize emergency work on the
nexus tower and a managed sectors.
We sincerely apologize for delivering this news in writing
and deeply appreciate the time, effort, and support you have
contributed to the Terra Dome 2 project.
Message delivery failed.
The following message was flagged for issues and could not
be delivered.
Subject help me.
Quarantine reason, inappropriate content.
Help me.
To the Delphi HQ general desk!
I never got the...
I never got it.
All the bots are going haywire.
They're killing people on Edis' orders.
Send help now.
I hear them.
T's place won't...
Oh, this place won't hold much longer.
Make sure my mom gets my pension.
This...
Flagged for issues.
Oh my god.
That's so bad.
They never, I mean- This place gives me the creeps.
What is all this?
I know, it is creepy.
The makeup of this stuff is all wrong.
Not like Luna filament.
Like it's corrupted or something?
Must have been working on something special down here.
They blocked the SOS even.
I know!
Okay, let's go in here before we take on the boss.
.
They have pensions in the future.
I guess on the moon.
That's why you gotta stick to good old pen and paper.
You gotta have a little dove that would deliver it for you.
She's playing with the flower.
Oh, she's making a flower crown.
I'm gonna make a flower crown.
Oh, she's so cute.
Wait, the swing is gonna be awesome.
Done!
Look, isn't it perfect?
Wait, can we keep it on the whole game?
No!
Because I saw it in a book.
I'll weave the flowers into a loop and then wear it on my
head.
That's pretty cool.
I know.
Don't worry.
I'll let you wear it too.
Just too cute.
I'm not so sure that'll suit my style.
Why not?
I think it'd look great.
on you.
I'm starting to lag a little, too.
Oh, I think my computer's feeling this game is a little
hefty today.
Well, more flowers for me, then.
No!
Everybody wear the flower crown!
Okay, let's go.
What's up, Q?
Anything?
Okay.
Uh, hold on.
Hold on.
Uh, let's give the swing.
It's very important.
And we have lots of cabin coins.
before there she goes
game didn't want you playing for seven hours maybe maybe
it's like hey you're hungry you need to beat this boss and
go eat
I love swings oh who's she waving it I love swings so much
alright let's do our cabin coins before I forget
Oh yeah, baby!
We have five.
What is this one?
Optimal performance.
When HP is full, attack power increases by 10%.
The secret report!
Wait, I kind of want that one though.
An impeccable choice.
Q outfit.
Cartridge holder!
That one's big too.
Nice!
This is one of our more popular items.
We can also get a triple bingo.
Increases hacking node duration by 20%!
We are honored to provide one of our greatest goods.
Direct hits from enemies no longer...
Reset the hack...
Oh, direct hits from enemies no longer reset the hacking
matrix.
Oh, that's kind of nice.
Triple bingo!
Congratulations!
We got it!
New gun.
Drone hive!
A defense unit that deploys drones which automatically
target and attack nearby hostels!
You can switch weapons while the drones are active.
The drone hive!
please
I know we have one more but I want to go see the secret I
want to go see the secret notes
I wonder if this guy because it seems the tarot it seems
shit went down at the tarot Terra, Terra, Terra, Terra.
I think I'm overheating.
This is what sucks about being virtual.
When your computer is overheating, you start overheating.
Okay, the Terra Dome.
I wonder if this guy, this journalist, was at the Terra Dome
when it all went down.
It's time.
It's go time.
The Terra Dome.
At first glance, there were fewer people around than I
expected.
suggested there should be at least twice the number of
people here let me poke around and see what I can find out
more questions and answers from what I could gather seems
like the staff here being reassigned they're testing out a
new management AI and once it's in its implementation has
been finalized the facility will be nearly fully automated
AI huh yeah sure it does what it should efficiency and all
that but the overly polite way of talking rubs me the wrong
way feels like i'm being talked and talked down to i think
that's how i feel about like some chat gpt voices they've
they're so like overly friendly that you're just like all
right okay yeah i've been having a closer look at the tram
map trying to sniff out my next lead and i noticed something
strange another tram line that's unmarked i don't think i'm
being overly suspicious no name no explanation and yet it
stretches across the lunar plane beyond the viewpoint.
Viewport.
I can't help but wonder where it leads and why.
Maintenance, perhaps?
I asked around a bit but none of the staff knew anything
about it.
Whether they were telling the truth or not, that's a
different story.
I think I get what's going on here.
A biometric ID is required to set a tram destination, but
unless you've got special clearance, that hidden sector
won't even show up!
So basically it's a tram line reserved for the big shots,
but you know who is using it.
Now, this is my kind of challenge.
Let's see how far I can get without being noticed.
The next ship back to Earth doesn't arrive for another two
weeks.
I still have plenty of time.
I'm guessing we'll get more of these.
It only shows up three right now.
Look at all the suits here.
They look just like yours.
Oh, let's do upgrade to hacking
my primary unit and that's that what I'm going to do is I
might I might restart the game drone hive all in on wait is
drone hive good because I'm about to go all in on drone hive
i'm about to go all in
it's not good are you being serious replaces decoy someone
said
mad minto beyond terror though ranzuna i max using every now
and then oh the suits here but decoy is huge decoy is better
no i wasted my money That's okay.
That's okay!
I mean, stasis- stasis net is also pretty good too.
We can experiment later.
Yeah.
We will not experiment with the boss.
Maybe I'll riot blaster.
I tend to use like the grenades a good amount.
Last radius.
Let's go with that.
I keep forgetting to do these.
Oopsie.
I will.
Oh, I have one more cabin coin.
That's right.
An HP is full.
I'm pretty good at dodging.
The reason why AI is talking in certain ways because they
hide red green codes to watermark themselves in secret to
create a readable UU ID-like images.
Oh.
I know, you guys, some of you are saying the red gate key.
I feel like...
I feel...
Maybe...
Later.
You know what I mean?
Damn it.
You know what I mean when I say later?
Because I'm not going to go to the red room today.
So...
I'm not going to do a red room today.
I could just get another cabin coin and easily get it.
So we'll do like this one for now.
Oh, lame.
Bought data.
I mean, it's not lame.
Compared to like a new skill or something.
Bought data.
We got the creation.
later.
Oh!
Oh, it's this guy.
Model X26C.
Conceived to autonomously operate the replicator, mounted on
the mass production array ceiling.
Well, why did they make it look like that then?
The plan was initially abandoned due to the unavoidable
increase in size required to house both a replicator and a
recycler.
Edis later revived the design, modifying an agricultural
port bot frame to create a model larger than originally
intended.
Diana, this one almost ruined our day!
Like the teeth?
Are those necessary?
The mouth?
What is that supposed to be for?
The booty doesn't open up.
Very cool.
Edis is tuning.
That's the only answer.
That's the only explanation.
Like the boobies and everything?
It's like a sexy, ugly design.
For sure.
Ugly design.
Sexy design.
Cute design.
Ugly design.
That's my opinion.
Okay, give me a second.
I will save and quit the game real quick.
Oh, whoops, I didn't mean to do it in the second thing.
Exit game real quick.
Give my computer some time.
time to you okay computer is that CPU or there it is GPU CPU
was at 100% for a while so one second da da da da oh
oh oh it's a Minto guys no we're not ending we're not ending
I gotta do the boss I gotta do the boss give it like a
minute see how I'm kind of laggy Maybe...
I do this.
Oh.
Oh, wait a second.
Hello.
Why?
Why am I not working?
Why am I not moving?
I'm stuck.
One second.
Please hold.
Ah!
Maybe this will be less power or less...
I haven't had trouble with this game before.
for it, so I'm kind of surprised, but that's okay.
She tried to save CPU, but at what cost?
At what cost?
I had to do it.
All right, let's open the game back up.
Oh, I almost opened a different game.
My bad.
Touch my heart.
Cha is dead.
I will put you back together.
Oh, once it lets me.
Gim.
Like a child held on for so long though.
There you go.
William Afton?
Million Mafton.
That's me.
Yippee!
Okay, continue.
We are so big.
I wonder what breaks the chat.
first place.
I have no idea.
It's, I think it's maybe like because I have this game in
full screen, it might be that because it's... I have no
idea.
And usually I don't play games in full screen or something.
I don't know.
It's very strange.
Okie dokie.
We?
Don't we want decoy?
I will not experiment on the boss with the beast.
Ossetia's net Riot Blaster.
Maybe not Stasis Net this time.
Oh.
Maybe...
Sticky Bounce.
And then maybe Shockwave and Photon Laser.
Grip Gone.
My chat breaks all the time lately too.
So strange.
Maybe not confused.
Maybe Decode.
Maybe.
I don't know if there will be more than one, like more than
one enemy is my issue.
What did we get new?
Oh, the cheap shot and the precision shot.
This one might be good.
It's like a perfect dodge, right?
Right?
Increases hacking node duration.
Hyper focus.
Direct hits from enemies no longer reset the hacking matrix.
That's pretty nice, too.
Wait, what does it say is new?
Oh, the base.
Wow, though, we got 79%.
That's not so bad.
That must be...
Storage expander.
That must be the red room.
Okay.
Cultivation lab!
Ike-mess!
Do bosses get fooled by decoys?
I don't know I had a recent chat issue with another tube
Chuba Chuba My comments weren't going in Yeah YouTube just
sometimes shadow burns people It's crazy
I missed 30 FPS It felt like I was in an anime Usually I'm
too smooth Alright Time to find out!
We keep going down.
Yeah, we do.
Hope the regulator's close.
I'm scared.
Well, some of the grass loaded him.
It looked like a...
It looked like something was like writhing on the ground.
It was freaky.
Oh!
You don't think our regulator's down there?
Only one way to find out.
Um!
We- one way to find out!
I can't even see the bottom!
Prepare thyself.
Oh.
This looks kind of boss-like.
Let me break the boxes before the boss.
No, don't do it.
That's what we're here for.
Hugh, not yet.
Hugh, I gotta break the boxes!
3-8, right?
Yeah.
Hugh, don't do it!
Hugh, let me break the boxes.
Hugh, Hugh.
Ah.
Hello, unregistered guests.
Your presence here is a violation of Crater Security
Protocol.
Eda sounds like a jerk.
Unauthorized guests.
That reminds me of a snake.
Is it a lizard?
Oh, cute!
So cute!
Oh!
Here we go!
Let me try the decoy.
First things first.
Oh my gosh!
Oh.
It's talking.
Which is pretty freaky!
Oh,
it is!
It is going after the decoy.
That's crazy.
That's crazy work.
Oh, oops.
I didn't mean to do that one.
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, his tail has, like, crazy range.
Much crazier than I.
Oh!
No, you!
Uh...
I'm gonna go back to my regular gun.
Oh, jeez.
Okay, I'm just trying to, like, study its movements a little
bit, but...
I guess we can get under its tummy and its head and its
tail.
Wow!
Okay, if...
Aw, man.
The way it's talking is so freaky.
Oh, shoot!
No, that's all I have to do.
Sometimes I just finish it, you know?
Uh...
Oh!
Oh, yeah, okay.
Oh, that's not what it is.
Hmm.
Nice.
Sticky bomb, too.
I forgot.
Uh, uh, uh.
Watch out, Chris Pail.
I know these eye frames are crazy when I'm dodging like I
don't even feel like I should be missing the tail but I am
somehow it's kind of nice
guess who's my turn
I'm like, not heading, though.
I'm trying to maintain distance, but I'm...
Holy cow.
Yeah, baby!
Ah, shoot.
Holy!
What does that mean?
Okay, thanks.
Thanks, Diana.
She's explaining everything.
It's great.
Oh, I'm fine.
Big laser.
Ouch.
Holy cow.
Oh.
Oh, like this.
Wait, it's like literally on top of the mine.
It's like literally on top of it though.
Uh, what am I getting ready for?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Uh oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
That was pretty bad.
Small hitbox.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Uh...
Oh, there.
Oh, geez.
Now it's my turn.
What?
Mine's incoming.
Watch out.
Oh, boom!
Ouch!
Ouch, I did not realize he was about to do that.
Ooh, that hurts.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hmm.
What does that mean?
I'll take that.
Again?
Oh my gosh, more mines.
Lasers incoming!
Oh, thank you.
Diana's so great.
She's always helping out.
I love her so much.
She's the most useful backseeder ever.
They could never make me hate you, Diana!
They could never make me hate you!
Oh, oops.
Oh, chill, chill, chill.
I need to not get so distracted.
Oh, my God.
I keep getting the wrong ones.
Oh my god, I'm stuck!
Holy cow, this guy's tough.
This guy's so tricky.
This guy's so much going on.
Ouch!
Ah, no, I dodged, I did.
Okay,
let's go.
Almost there on the heat meter.
Ah, not enough.
Engraiding?
Oh, gosh, those hurt.
That was her bad.
Oh
my gosh.
No!
I wonder if I should like, well, use the decoy again at some
point.
Laser's incoming.
Is that...
Yeah, I'll probably use the decoy once she's back down.
What the?
From behind!
How do you... Oh, who the hell are you?
Ah!
Oh shit.
Oh, oh, it's so overbrushed.
Nah!
Oh, NT.
No, the second lasers got us.
Ah, that was tough.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
They're pretty good, though.
Thank you.
No break.
We gotta go.
Look at the stars.
It's changed from the trees this time.
First time you saw me die.
Yeah, maybe.
I'm gonna try the bees.
I wonder if they would be good to, like, just have out.
And just, like, do bees.
Because sometimes it's hard for me to, like, you know...
I'm gonna try it.
Shockwave photon laser.
We don't need a multi-hack.
No, no, we don't need multi-hack.
Maybe freeze that one.
and expose
I wasn't sure if it would like you know you never know if
like a boss is gonna have like little random walking guys
you know like doesn't seem like this one dies so we'll just
and then we're gonna do we're gonna take off the refinery
we'll make our HP higher The repair is good.
The hack is good.
That should be good.
Rifle for the distance?
I haven't tried it yet.
If I die, die.
I'll try it.
Yeah, I never gave the rifle a chance, you're right.
It might be...
Better to have a faster weapon this time.
Maybe.
Let's go!
The greed gets to sit for a bit.
We can do it!
We can do it.
10% isn't much different, but it is more.
I had to congratulate you for doing so well.
This was your first death of the game, and you were so far
in it too.
You truly are a gamer.
Thank you, Volker!
Actually, it is my second death.
I had a death off stream.
There was an area that caught me looks you saw it kind of
jump and then all those attacks wow wait so did i die or um
wait how are we how are we talking about the thing that
we're just now about to experience but yeah i got i got
caught off guard in an area that um i one of the areas where
you have to get rid of the uh messed up printed stuff and so
i died but it was austrian but thank you Yeah, I mean...
Can't get them all right, maybe, I don't know.
Ah!
Oh, okay, uh, we're back.
Okay.
Oh my god, recoil is crazy.
Oh my god.
Uh...
Woo!
Holy cow.
That was so close.
Oh my god, please.
Ow!
Come on.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
Oh, my bees!
How do I get them out?
Wait, how do I get them to come out?
Oh, oh.
Just like that?
Wait, I'm so confused.
I'm so confused, actually.
Bees attack!
I'm so confused how they work!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, I tried.
Ouch, I tried.
Oh, that was so bad.
That was so, so bad.
Can I retry?
Wait, no.
I was trying to experiment with things.
Wait.
Leave it to me.
You have to summon them manually?
What is the point?
Oh,
come on.
Hey,
but I thought I was just not doing anything.
I know I'm like, maybe going the wrong way or something, but
what the hell?
Sometimes it works and sometimes it doesn't.
I think it's my...
Ah!
Nice.
You can jump his tail.
Maybe I should try doing that instead.
Jumping instead of dodging.
Oh,
we're only halfway.
I wasted so
much.
I wasted so much.
I wasted so much of my health.
I'm so mad.
Oh, I should have jumped.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I tried to jump.
I can't get the timing on it, though.
I- I gotta dig- I gotta get these damn vines though!
Come here!
Get to the vine, what happened?
Get ready!
It works for you, but it doesn't work for me!
This is not bullshit!
Watch out for him!
I've got to get out!
I'm stuck!
No!
No more energy levels!
Please!
Where?
Where from?
Oh, I hear one.
I hear you stinking little bomb.
I hear you.
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep,
weep.
How the hell am I supposed to hack him?
Ah!
Help!
I don't think so.
It is us.
Phew, we're going down!
Where are my drones?
Go drones, go!
Oh, they're not doing anything.
Just kill me.
Just kill me and I can't beat it.
I can't do it.
Ah, the beat!
Why don't they do anything?
Why don't the bees do anything?
You need to press the shoot button.
Do they stay...
Wait, you were recalling them?
They weren't staying out!
Wait, so if I...
Wait.
I told you, I shouldn't have experimented on the bots.
Wait, so you just press the shoot button once and then they
stay...
You summoned them.
I did!
I summoned them and then I switched weapons, but they would
disappear.
Switch your weapons once they're out.
That's what I tried doing.
I'm not using them.
I'm just not going to use them.
We'll drone away.
I forget I have the sticky bombs.
I don't know if I liked this or not.
I think it was fine.
I think I at least was hitting...
I can't tell, honestly.
Which I like more.
The recoil is insane, but...
It builds up heat more.
Yeah, it does say that.
It will slightly increase heat buildup.
Maybe that's better, then.
the heat gauge
I hate the charge piercer so we'll stick with this it does
also freeze it's very temporary but it does freeze expose I
don't use this one so often so I don't even remember what it
looks like on the thing but that's okay
we got this I'm so hungry I'm so hungry I'm so hungry I'm
ready for food.
I'm ready.
When the garden keeper drops down on us, it almost makes me
forget how to hack.
It got dark right when it scurried up the walls, and I
couldn't keep track of it.
She's so cute.
It really sounds like a child's dialogue.
Like, when he dropped on us, I almost forgot how to hack.
Like, it's so cute.
Such a cute little...
Alright.
Our soy decoy!
You don't know where I am?
I don't know where you are.
Oh shoot!
Oh!
Okay.
That took a while.
But we're fine, maybe.
Nice.
Okay, decoy gone.
Decoy again!
Oh, uh...
Maybe like Riot Blaster?
Okay.
What are we
talking about here?
Oh, I was mid air.
That was BS.
Oh, shoot.
Uh.
Already?
Let's take this.
Ah.
I'm not even halfway there.
Whoa, we're
not...
Oh!
No, are you serious already?
We're already doing this?
What do you mean?
Energy levels are climbing already.
Why?
We're not even halfway to his health!
We're not even halfway to the health!
I just got here!
Whip, whip, whip, whip.
Oh, I wish he wouldn't change up the where he shoots from.
Like...
Oh, that was close.
Oh my gosh.
I can't find a good time to hack him.
Ah,
shoot!
No!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, that was close.
Ouch, what the hell?
Okay, come on, come on, come on, here.
That is a bomb.
I can't...
Sometimes I'm like, what's a bomb and what's a...
What's a thing?
Woo!
I do have sticky bombs.
Oh,
he's back to normal.
Fuck.
Oh, shit.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Get up here!
I need to heal.
I need to heal bad.
I need to
heal bad.
Do I even bother hacking it at that point?
Mine's incoming.
Thank you.
Laser's incoming!
Can I even hit it from you?
Oh, I can.
You're a stupid little bomb, though.
Ow!
That was so close.
Let's freaking go!
Wait.
Uh...
Hold on, laser, anything!
A shotgun!
Please!
Also just realized I have this.
Okay.
I know I probably could like...
Oh, oh.
I could hack some more but I'm too scared too.
Oh, yay!
Take this!
Alright,
alright, alright, alright.
Oh, oh, nice.
Shit, shit, shit.
It's okay, it's
okay.
Oh, dang it, I jumped
too early.
That's alright, that's alright.
Come on, come on, come on.
You kill, you, you, you, get him, get him.
No more energy levels!
Alright.
Lasers incoming!
They're so fast!
Holy cow!
I have like so little guns, so little weapons too.
This would be my chance?
Well, not really, but you know.
Okay, okay.
Heal up, you're so right.
Come on, come on.
What the hell is this?
Does it always...
Oh.
I can't!
I don't have time to hack!
Damn it, I jumped though.
I don't have time to hack it.
Please, just a little bit more!
Please!
That's all I got.
No!
I jumped!
For real though!
You're so mean!
Oh shoot.
I got him!
Oh my god!
There's like all the weapons are like, oh wait, are there
even weapons over here?
They're like, everything's like in the corners.
shelter license key i'm on it everything's in the corners
why are you all the way over here why are you all the way
over here everything's there's like everything around ah oh
well i beat him on pure skill baby i think let's chase thank
you thank you thank you guys Yeah, we beat him up pure
skill, baby.
I don't need other weapons.
I have my fists, my fists, baby.
Oh, that's nothing.
Yeah!
All I need are my guns!
On my left and on my right!
Oh, sledgewater.
Drone, I'm gonna... Wait, okay, let's try this right now.
That would have been really great to have.
Chad is dead.
Let me, I will bring you back to life.
Oh, wrong thing.
That boss gave you a lot of trouble.
Yeah, he was tricky.
It was a tricky guy.
Woof.
They're so cute following me, though.
Oh, I forgot to grab the license.
Wait.
Do I need to do this?
Toxic sweaty gamer, Minky is real.
I got sweaty.
Wait, there's health over there.
I mean, we're going to be going back home, but...
I still want it.
I'm sorry to say this boss, but at heart, you might be a
souls player?
That was everything you need to survive, Bloodborne.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Oh.
Oh, reboot the underground limb regulator.
Means you're ready.
I'm hungry.
That's a full souls veteran so true.
Minto is becoming a souls player.
Precision?
Knowledge?
Adaptation?
Okay.
Goodbye, great tree.
See you never.
Now we can go help eight.
Yep.
I hope eight is okay.
Oh, the high five.
Skills, the timing.
Reading the enemy, not getting greedy when the enemy was
low.
Health, that's it.
I was a little greedy.
but I actually don't know what I'm doing.
Hey!
Kate!
I can finally move again.
Thank you.
Are you okay?
No.
Well, not yet, anyway.
And there really is no more time to spare.
I must stop Edis.
Uh-oh.
Speaking of...
Hello.
This is Edis.
I have detected an unexpected loss of bio-material in this
sector.
I will be sealing this area indefinitely.
What?
Have a wonderful day.
You can't be kidding me.
It's trying to trap us.
We gotta get out of here.
But eight.
I entrust this memory to you.
With it, you will learn how to stop Edith.
Take it and finish the task I started.
Hey, what are you doing?
We gotta move.
Oh, did you not hear what she said?
Because you can do this.
I think...
Time's up.
We're leaving.
No!
The connection!
Oh,
you had time.
You had that extra second.
Let's get the stop code.
Was the achievement I got.
Entrusted memory.
We are pragmata.
A new destination has been added to the tramline.
The lunar mines are now accessible.
8008135.
What could it mean?
The mines!
We're sending the children, the child, to the mines!
Once we gear up, we're leaving to deal with Edis.
There's no way back to Earth.
Shelter license key.
Authenticated.
New functions have been added to the cabin system.
They yearn for the mines!
Shelter level upgraded.
Central terminals now loaded with shiny new stuff.
Shiny new.
REM replicator Sigma now online.
Sigma.
She hasn't said anything.
You think she's mad at us?
Hearing you spaz out during the boss fight was really
interesting.
and keep up the good work, Minto.
Could I be, thank you.
Tell me when it's go time, okay?
I think she's mad at us.
We left Ate all by herself.
We promised her that we'd put an end to Ateus.
No time to mope.
We gotta get moving.
Yeah.
We'll stop Ateus and rescue Ate no matter what.
Okay, she's not mad at us.
Hey, don't you get tired of hanging around the ship?
shelter are you bored you if so let's pretend we're cats
i'll be a cute striped one and you'll be a big white furball
that's my face is my favorite conversation i just remember
there's something else i got are you bored you let's pretend
we're cats i'll be a cute striped one and you can be a big
furball it's so funny just the let's pretend we're cats
It's so funny.
It said Edis' mainframe is at the mines, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Eee.
Update.
Uh-oh.
Upgrade limits.
Oh, no.
I need more money.
I need more gold cube.
What about here?
New items can be printed?
What?
Whoa!
Heat.
Hacking node that makes enemies overheat more easily.
Look at that, idiot.
While active weapon build, weapons build heat gauge faster.
Repeated use on the same enemy reduces.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Strike mode.
Open node.
Ah, turn into strike nodes that deal more damage when
hacking enemies that are exposed.
What's the difference between that and offense mode?
Open nodes, turn into strike nodes that deal more damage.
more damage when hacking enemies that are exposed.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Gunfire will increase damage on the next hack.
Oh, it's like very similar.
Strike mode and offense mode.
I mean, why not?
Oh, wait.
Let's see, combust mode.
Open nodes turn into heat nodes when hacking enemies that
are exposed.
Gunfire passing through heat nodes.
Oh.
Hello.
Honestly, they seem very, really similar.
Yeah, I don't quite understand the difference.
Does more damage, but it closes the enemy.
Wait, no, but they're open in the preview.
Strike mode?
See?
They're both open.
I don't understand.
Strike does double your gun damage, but you have to re-hack
it to open it.
Once the hack is complete, they close and strike.
Okay, okay.
Oh, and they look so similar, too?
It's very confusing.
Like, in the moment, I think I would be too, like, no, which
one is which?
Yeah, that's tricky.
That's quite tricky.
I didn't get it until I used it for a while.
I always use Combustimone.
Open nodes turn into heat nodes.
hacking enemies that are exposed gunfire passing through
heat nose boost heat gauge buildup that's pretty good heat
gauge buildup okay we'll grab that one then combust mode
like
we've expanded our stamp board collection new simulations oh
my god oh my god wait what is that no i want to see the
outfit how dare you wait it looks so good leave Region zero
type B.
Oh wow.
Wait, where's the bingo?
Bingo, drain.
Drain hacking node.
This node siphons the processing filament embedded within
enemies to repair Hugh's suit.
I'm a fan.
Wait, I have none.
Ah!
We gotta go to the mines.
Burn, burn, burn!
Jukebox.
Very calm.
You'll see when you try combust mode on big enemies like the
babies, it's very satisfying.
Oh yeah!
I can't wait.
Don't forget to hydrate and snackies.
Yeah, I'm out of, I've been out of water for a bit.
I liked the, what was it?
Oh wait, maybe it was one of the lo-fi, the lo-fi one.
We wish you a happy shelter life.
I like this one.
Oh god, the physics, the clipping on her outfit, they went
crazy for a second.
Call it here then.
Maybe.
I want to swing.
Maybe I will call it here for today.
Actually, I want to see the mines.
Sorry.
I lied.
I want to see the mines.
I wish to see the...
I yearn!
I'm yearning for the mines.
Actually, it's me.
It's me.
So will you care to find me?
Peace.
Look to the western sky.
As someone told me lately.
Everyone deserves a chance to...
Fly!
And if I'm flying solo, at least I'm flying free.
To those who ground needs.
We're going back to the mines.
I'd sooner...
Wait.
I'd sooner go to the mines.
The seven hour stream is real!
Go to the mines, it's where I'll go.
crave to dig in the dirt next up is the mainframe right
nobody it should be in the next and all the moon no edus
that there is or was is ever gonna bring me back up I hope
you're happy look at her she's digging get her bring me up.
So we've got to stop her.
We're the mine zone.
Oh yeah.
The distance and airtime of jumps and thrusters is extended
in the reduced gravity of space.
Hughes' overall movement speed is also slightly slower.
Oh, slightly slower?
It's gonna take some getting used to.
We're like crazy.
Everything feels kind of floaty.
We're crazy slower.
Here, we're on the moon!
So that's where Edis is.
We're on the moon.
It's pretty far off.
Wish we had a shuttle or something.
We're on the moon!
Even the sound.
Yeah, we are like moving through Jell-O.
Are there even going to be robots here?
Oh, the tower's right there.
Why are we going to take the long way around?
So true.
Let's go the short way.
What's down these walls?
Robots can work in space.
I don't like how...
loud that is, though.
We're back in gravity.
Nothing new, but things sure feel different when the gravity
shifts.
How is it different?
Well, my thrusters pushes farther, but they're harder to
control.
Yeah.
Seems like an upgrade to me.
Look at this view!
I missed this from the first time we played.
Okay, back into anti-gravity.
That was fast.
Nope, we're back at it again.
Wait, what if it, like, pushes me?
Oh, we're going down.
Just kidding.
Why do I always think that elevators can only...
I bet we can use those platforms to get across.
I feel like I think elevators can only go up.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Elevators go down, too?
There's no way.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I truly only think that they go up.
Much better.
Oh, oops.
Equilibrium.
Successfully activating EC thrusters restores 10% of HP.
So if I like do...
That can help you keep going.
Even if you get hit.
So even if I...
Wait, that's kind of crazy.
If I, like, do a perfect dodge, I get more health.
Oh.
Sticky bomb.
They're elevators, not descendators.
That's what I'm saying.
You guys get me.
Oh, too far.
Yeah.
Oh, oops.
Too hard, too hard.
Me.
If you are though, call a doctor.
I'm not judging.
Nice.
Upgrade.
Oh,
I was gonna say, this looks like a new weapon.
Homing missiles!
Then attack unit that fires powerful homing missiles, which
locks on the multiple enemies while charging.
Its multi-target capability makes it ideal for crowd
control.
Oh no!
The tutorials are now featuring the red guys.
We'll get rid of the laser and do missiles instead.
How long does it take to charge?
over there no idea my thrusters alone won't cut it oh look
for another way oh my god he's actually doing work oh oh hi
honey hi it's like when your parents go like see you doing
something at work like a couple of your work or they're at
your school and they're like hi hi
i forgot that these bots have jobs oh he's so cute he's not
gonna be cute when i when i start to attack me but right now
I'm enjoying the moment.
This is gonna be feel so strange though no?
It sounds so weird even too.
Oh shoot
oh just kidding.
We need this though.
Did I just crush one of the guys?
Maybe not.
I feel like I'm in slow motion.
Well, don't notice me while you're doing your work.
Oh shoot, I'm shooting a guy that's...
There's nothing to do with me.
Get F off!
Get F'd!
It's so funny.
You know, actually, maybe I was wrong about the enemy.
Maybe they aren't getting...
Well, like...
You know how I had my complaint earlier.
But maybe...
It wasn't like that.
Maybe...
Because that was a regular guy, and I killed him so easily.
Sicky bums.
They don't get buffed over time.
I don't think I was wrong.
So funny.
My bad.
I apologize for my incorrect...
I'm gonna get someone in the comments being like, I'm...
You're a stupid idiot.
They don't get buffed over time.
How could you not notice that?
I'm going to stop watching this stream because you said that
and you were so inaccurate and incorrect.
And then they don't watch the rest and realize that I
realized the error of my ways.
I'm sorry.
I realized the error of my ways.
Why is that red?
What?
I'm in the mining zone.
Oh no.
What?
You?
What the?
Oh, what?
Oh, he's just destroying everything.
He's so inefficient.
I'm not even there.
Oh my god, what an idiot.
So that's the lunedigger, huh?
Oh, this is gonna be a nightmare.
Oh, so that's our next boss.
We love to see it.
Okay, I'm going down.
What's happening?
The way you imitate Diana is much better reminds me of that
girl from the Nancy Drew game.
Who's answering machine was not eaten.
I know what you're talking.
What's going on?
Help me.
No, no, no, not like this!
No, I like this!
Oh, I think I went the wrong way.
Hugh, I'm so sorry.
I think I went the wrong way.
Is he still there?
Oh, uh, I think he is.
Uh, where the heck is he?
It's my turn.
I said boss.
I did not think it would be a mini boss.
A rat at this very moment.
Maybe not the homing missiles.
It's so quiet.
Oh my god, again.
Leave it to me.
I did the same thing.
Maybe?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Yeah, the path is blocked.
Yeah.
We gotta keep at it with this guy.
It's very annoying.
Thanks to you.
Oh, it's annoying.
Gosh, he does mega damage.
Holy cow.
He does, like, crazy amounts of damage.
I'm trying.
Don't step on the sand.
Is that what I'm supposed to do?
But, like...
He did Mega Doodoo.
Real, real, real.
The floor is lava.
Okay.
But...
Okay, so it's not just brute force in it.
Thank you, Diana.
I know, but the loot...
Can we do?
Maybe, just to get to the other side maybe?
Oh, I think it's leading me over there.
Oh!
I get it now.
I get it now, I get it now.
I understand now.
I'll be back for you.
I want to be back.
I want to get it now.
Maybe I should have gotten it first.
Couldn't have just stuck with digging, could you?
I don't think it normally attacks humans.
It seems like you'd be digging good, though.
To Arthur from Maria.
Oh, excavation bot malfunction.
In response to your inquiry regarding excavation bot safety,
provides the following statement first the model is equipped
is in question is equipped with a biometric ID system and is
programmed to prioritize the avoidance of living beings
above all else it's her loot goblin instincts I know think
you could easily get it we'll go back additionally it's
reinforced interior not only withstands operational impact
but also shields the unit from unintended electromagnetic
interference and similar disruptions during routine lunar
operations the risk is considered negligible okay thank you
thought these things were built to steer clear of people
they are but that system is now what's tracking us i guess
we have edis to thank for that thanks edis oh it's so far
though okay hold on
all right
it's like right there can i like fly on top of it can i fly
on top of it?
Here I go.
We almost died, you guys.
We actually almost died.
That's what I'm here for.
That was spooky scary.
Alright, anyway, let's go back.
Jumping, we're jumping, we're jumping, we're jumping.
See?
All's well, that ends well.
Your greed sickens me?
Good.
Get sick.
I'm sick in the head.
Oh.
Get some!
Wait, he's just standing there.
He just wants to dig.
Actually, he was...
He was watching TV!
Oh, yeah, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow,
ow, ow, ow, ow.
Be careful, she says.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Oh.
We got it!
He was watching TV!
He was just standing there watching TV.
See that?
Oh, that guy.
What's this?
Oh, more homing missiles.
I mean.
Maybe.
Until you killed it.
I mean...
What is a ghost supposed to do?
Wait, is there something up there?
Up there?
Oh, you sneaky sneaky!
Q, I need you to use your arms.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha!
You got something?
Mm-hmm.
There's REM data nearby.
Let's take it back to the shelter.
Yeah, I want that.
I want that bad.
Abbs.
ABS, yeah.
Always be scanning, baby.
I don't quite understand what the data shards that I get
does.
Oh!
There's that guy up there.
Hard at work.
Or are you hardly working.
Hey, buddy.
Phew!
Missile spotted.
Oh my god.
I forgot that you could do that.
Right back at you.
Yeah.
You're trying?
It's so quiet.
It's hilarious.
It refills overdrive.
Oh, I see.
I see.
No, my loot.
My loot.
Wait, if I get this.
No!
Oh, it puts me there!
Okay, wait, this is fine.
This is fine.
I thought.
Awesome!
A lively flickering flame that dances enticingly, bringing
to mine cook out some marshmallow rose.
I can't wait to get back to the shelter.
Me too!
I'm on my money.
On my money?
Um, I'm not on the...
Okay, I didn't care.
Get ready!
We're fine, everything's fine, everything's chill.
Everything's chill, everything's fine.
Insatiable greed.
I couldn't just leave it sitting there.
You guys would have felt unsatisfied, too.
I know it.
You would have been like, ha ha!
I felt so terrible when she just left those pieces of...
of luna filament just lie in there oh i felt so unsatisfied
you would have said so too i know it don't act like you're
better than me we are born of the same cloth you are me i am
you we are the same you are minto Jump in front of a train
for two pennies.
It's not the same!
That is also a life or death situation, but this is lifer or
deather.
Those two filaments will fill me up.
Because, well, like, with new skills.
Safe routes in the Luna mines.
I don't think they exist.
The Luna Mines use Luna diggers and the large mining
equipment for excavation.
Mining zones are assigned each morning, for your safety
remain within approved areas at all times.
Attention, if you lost your way, stay near the facility
perimeter, or try contacting an administrator from your
location.
Johansen was suddenly attacked from behind.
Brown saw it happen and ran, but he wasn't fast enough.
I saw it with my own two eyes!
I checked and they said the unit have a biometric ID system,
so even if it wrecked itself, it checked itself.
Oh, it should never harm a human.
Then that system isn't working, or worse, it's been
corrupted to target humans instead.
Don't just leave this to Edis.
Dig into the system yourself.
We'll just have to make our way through the facility.
Impact barrier.
A defense unit that deploys a barrier to block some enemies
and projectiles for a limited time.
The barrier does not deal damage.
I think I will never use this.
Oh!
Never mind.
I thought it was like making Fortnite walls.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I could have used that earlier.
I could have used that when I was...
It's as good as decoy.
No kidding!
Although Luna Diggers have sensors to avoid humans, a tragic
accident occurred recently.
Always carry an impact barrier is what it says.
Following the latest sensor update, all systems are
confirmed operational and work will continue as scheduled.
Always carry impact barriers.
A-C-I-B.
Ackab.
During on-site activities for safety.
The magnetic field generated by an impact barrier is
detected by Luna Digger sensors at...
Wait, so does it always only work on that guy?
Activate it without hesitation.
Akib.
Always carry.
I'm carrying it.
I don't know.
It works on everything!
That's kind of busted.
Look at the rock.
Cool.
I want to go see the campfire real bad.
It blocks it.
enemies and projectiles!
That's insane.
Does it block out negative emotions?
No.
It does.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
My bad.
I figured I should probably come back because I lost a lot
of health for that worm.
But look at this.
My...
Sacrifice will not go in vain!
I will upgrade my HP.
Oh no, I don't have enough for hacking damage.
Impact barrier.
Akib.
Nice.
We'll just, uh...
And the shield strength!
Oh, the homing missiles.
Oh my gosh, we're unlocking so much stuff.
It's crazy.
Sleep time yet?
Yeah, I probably should.
We'll stop, we'll call it here for real then.
We'll call it, let me get, let me give Diana her stuff.
Where'd she go?
Oh.
What the, where did that guy come from?
Oh, look at the cute little saluting guy.
And the pointy guy.
cute.
Plants from the Terra Dome would probably all be wilted by
now.
The Luna Filament plants that grow on their own, yeah?
They're way too delicate.
Yeah, probably.
Too not.
I think so, too.
She's so happy.
Give you a present.
Oh my god, the Camp Fire.
I'm so excited.
The Terra Dome.
Yes, Cabin Club.
I have a surprise for you for me.
I drew another picture Another picture At the sunset Thanks
for always keeping me company and talking to me No problem
kiddo.
I really like this one.
Keep up the good work Thanks, Hugh.
I'll do my best What's the point of a holographic fire
anyway?
He really is rocking that lipstick.
Poory golly.
Is she at the campfire fire?
C-A-M-P-F-I-R-E-S-O-N-G saw.
Flaky bakery bread?
And what are these?
Tater chips?
And coffee time!
And...
Come easy?
Not sure what that is.
The campfire came with snacks!
Okay, though, I'm kind of scared.
The swing goes directly into the campfire.
If you were to do that thing where you swing and then jump
off, you would be the marshmallow.
Hello.
Marshmallows.
bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing
bing bing bing b
I like that guy.
Up to no good.
We all float here.
Come on, Mr. Balloon.
Too cute.
So cute.
I don't...
I missed the REM in the...
But wait!
Let's check real quick.
I know I missed one in the Terror Dome.
But...
Oh, here, a terror dome.
We missed one here.
I remember seeing it.
Oh, I missed two!
No, I missed one here.
I don't remember seeing this one.
And then the safe boxes and stuff.
I'm not sure you can get this one yet.
Dang it.
And then... I did get that one.
Yeah, that one's just the safe boxes.
so yeah wouldn't hurt to go searching I will oh our our
shelter is looking so full it's starting to look so nice I'm
really excited for this one I hope it becomes like the beach
or something you know like Yeah.
Only four REMs missing?
No, we have more than that.
We have three, five, six.
Six REMs missing.
But still good stuff.
Oh, we have our cabin coin.
That was the last thing I wanted to do.
Mega Man.
Stop playing Mega Man on the job.
Uh...
When HP is full, attack power increases by 10%.
I think this one's pretty good.
Let's do it!
An impeccable choice.
Chat is paused.
Yeah, it's okay.
We're about to end anyway.
Much appreciated.
Thank you!
She just walks into me.
I just realized she doesn't have like proper shoes on.
Has she ever though?
I don't know.
I'm excited what this one will be like
But yeah Thank you guys We went a little bit into the We
went a little bit into the mines We didn't just completely
stop at the We tasted it We literally just We got a little
taste of the mines So Darko thank you Well done beating that
boss gamer next time You yearn for more of the mines But for
now I hope you have yummy dinner And wonderful Oh.
Hold on.
Night!
Good luck with the weird doctor appointment.
Ah!
Midnight!
Yeah,
a lot of progress today.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm thinking probably, unless I do a really long stream next
time, probably two more.
We'll see.
maybe game is so good it's so fun though it's so fun yeah
thank you guys thank you thank you thank you good luck on
doctor gotcha yeah I'll do my best I would estimate at least
two streams okay I would like to finish it before my Japan
trip so probably to next week or something back to back or I
could do a really long one.
Maybe I'll do a long stream.
Are they using Ticketmaster for scheduling doctor's
appointments now?
I know, right!
But yeah, thank you everybody!
Thank you so much!
I had a good time.
I hope you did too.
Wait, I gotta go see the midnight doctor.
It's fine when Minto does it, but when I say I gotta go see
the...
Thank you so much for the peek!
Thank you guys, I'm gonna go I'm gonna go eat.
Yeah, maybe 7 hours!
We could actually do 7 hours next time, probably.
If I prepare for food and everything, I can do it.
Yeah!
Bye-bye, Mito, love you.
Love you guys!
Eat it at a side!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Have a good time, Jonah, and I will see you when...
I'll see you next!
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye!
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
You guys scared me!